hey guys pete here
it's time to talk about episode nine of
better call saul's final season
which for me right now is my favorite
episode of the series definitely my
favorite episode of the season
slightly edging out uh 607 but i mean
right now
i haven't been able to stop thinking
about it since it came out and um
every time i do i just think about
something else that was
just kind of perfect in it and it was uh
it was just a fantastic episode of
television and i have invited a couple
of my friends here to talk about it
today um i'll be introducing them in a
second i do want to let you guys know
that we have um
i've been thinking about this for a
while and this week we're going to try
it out for the first time
i'm going to do a preview stream on
saturday and so
we're gonna have um this week at least
we're gonna have courtney and chase uh
the vivid kiwi because neither one of
them can make that to make this one
today so
we'll have two different ones and um
we'll see how that goes and maybe we'll
do that for the rest of the way you know
the rest of the way till the end so
uh the episode was titled fun and games
it's all fun and games until someone
gets hurt or loses an eye or
the relationship comes to an end um
i'm gonna give you guys a chance to
introduce yourselves and then you could
tell me your overall thoughts on on the
episode where you know where it landed
for you how it felt what you thought
about it what you hope to see next
and then we'll circle back around and
i'll talk about that and then we'll
answer questions from everybody that's
got them so gail you want to go first
sure i'm gil from the one take youtube
channel where we talk about better call
saul and a bunch of other shows and we
do sawcast on that channel and on its
own podcast stream so thanks pete again
for having me on this week
i echo your sentiments i'm not
necessarily ready to say my favorite
episode of the entire series it's just
too hard to pick one out and there's
always that recency bias but i did love
the episode
and i knew i loved it as i was watching
it and then i tried to figure out what
about it struck such a cord and i think
there are a couple of things
one it's just hard to ignore the fact
that of course the transformation of
jimmy mcgill into saul goodman is a
complicated one and you don't have that
moment that gets memed so often of this
was the moment he was truly saul goodman
or this was the moment he was truly
heisenberg but if we ever were going to
have that moment we kind of had it here
we had that time jump or flash forward
that says essentially and then he became
saul goodman dot dot dot and i thought
they stuck the landing with that moment
so well
the context of it choosing to put it
right after the breakup with kim
i thought was perfect memorable and sort
of a landmark moment that i think people
will talk about long after the series is
done great song choice for the
introduction there too i thought and
then just overall this episode i think
we love better call saul because it's so
focused on character and it's so focused
on characters choices
and we know a lot of the choices they're
going to make because we know where mike
gus and jimmy end up in breaking bad but
i thought this episode gave so much
context to those choices it showed us
the cost of those choices you look at
gus and see what he's giving up in favor
of a life focused on revenge
it helps us to understand kind of the
reality of mike's choice we understand
more why jimmy ends up where he did
so i loved the focus on on choice and in
a lot of the ways this episode almost
felt finale like it felt like goodbyes
to gus and mike even though we might see
them again
but
overall to me it's felt like we're
watching a several part finale
and and this really gave me that feeling
but the fun thing is there's still four
episodes left so so there's still more
story to tell
yeah yeah we're on the same page about
the um you know the way that the time
jumped worked and um
you know whenever you were talking about
that that moment that's the same thing i
opened my uh my recap video up with was
that idea that you know that's been the
thing that people have made fun of
anybody who who suggested the idea that
this is the moment where he becomes saul
goodman you know and for good reason in
some ways you know i mean
it it is something that happens as a
process
but i wonder if it's kind of a wink and
a nod you know if that had something to
do with their decision to do it i mean
it makes perfect sense you know when you
see it that abrupt change where he's
just he you know
how else could you do it's like ripping
off a band-aid you know what i mean you
just have to do it
and um you know the idea that he's on
this turntable bed maybe that we'll talk
about later because i don't know that i
i fully understand what the function of
that is
but i mean it it was it was
all the different ways you would think
it might happen
because you knew it was gonna happen
like you said
and then you know they still have that
ability to surprise us with things that
are are inevitable so it's pretty crazy
all right uh jim you want to introduce
yourself
yeah hey uh i'm jim from the bald move
network we do
a lot of podcasts on different tv shows
our better call saw podcast is called
better cast saul
which i do with my co-host aaron over
there
and we've been covering breaking bad
since season three all the way through
uh their call saul now so a lot of
history under the bell and man
this is an excellent episode this would
be an excellent episode of breaking bad
it's an excellent episode of better call
saul
the thing i particularly love about it
is
the way that they took kim from
uh
you know the person that we've known for
so long into
uh her final form here
and and how it felt like inevitable and
yet surprising at the same time because
i've always wondered like what is going
to be the thing that pushes kim over the
edge
makes her leave or is she getting killed
or what or how are they going to thread
this needle
and to have it be her decision
uh
because they're so bad together but well
they're so good together which makes
them so bad for everybody else
it's like a sacrifice right it's yeah
giving up someone she loves because she
knows that it's bad for everyone else
around her and that feels so kim to me
she wants to protect people right she
wants to help people
um and so i i was just
truly blown away by that scene like this
is this is the emmy scene this is the
scene they submit
to to have just win all the awards
because both yeah her second emmy
because this one will be the next year
right so right
for her for her back-to-back emmy
whenever that comes around
hopefully yeah no she's fantastic uh
i've never seen bob odenk odenkirk quite
this way before um yeah he's usually the
smooth talker the guy who's gonna play
the fool
this scene is so honest it's so real
and i don't know that i've ever seen
that from bob odenkirk before
so it was
very surprising and very uh rewarding to
see
yeah like i said it you know going into
this i i was at a point where i didn't
like any of the options anymore you know
they kind of narrowed things down as as
different you know things different
story lines wrapped up you know that you
know at a time going to prison seemed
like it might make sense um the the
vacuum cleaner guy seemed like it might
make sense a little bit during the
season
you know there was all these
obviously dying i never really thought
that would be a great um
way to go and
we really did hit a point where it was
just like none of these are going to be
satisfying because none of them are
really about kim
and and what she does you know i mean
they're all like
something has to happen to kim you know
what i mean
so i thought that was really remarkable
that they were able to come up with a
way where like you said that you know
it's it's her decision
you know she chooses this and you know
because
she believes it's the only way forward
and it's and it's brutal because you
know in that scene she kind of takes the
responsibility on herself like where she
says
uh you know this is um
you know i i did this because it was so
you know because it was so much fun
and it's sort of like letting him off
the hook or or trying to and and taking
it on for herself and and i feel like in
for him
he's kind of in a place where he's just
shell-shocked you know i mean like the
worst thing that he ever heard was just
you know he just he's just sitting with
it
and whatever she whatever's going on
with her it's it's almost like he can't
even uh you know
understand it or or process it like he
said i think bob did a great job of that
here of like showing that
this guy is is is is nearly catatonic
and you know what his what his wife is
doing is she's she's like
there there's there's a lot of you know
you don't we really don't know what's
going to happen to her afterwards but
she's not setting herself up to break
away so that she can have this wonderful
life that that she's being deprived of
it's kind of dark when you really think
about it
yeah it's what i loved i i wanted i came
into the season wanting something beyond
the pale to happen with howard i got
that
and then i get this excellent scene that
i didn't know i wanted but it was
exactly what i wanted
yeah
um
yeah so
another thing that you mentioned um gil
was the idea of choices and that was a
big thing that stood out for me too
i thought they set this up pretty well
in in the end of the last episode with
putting howard and and um
lala burying them next to each other
because that gave the the time for mike
to
to show us to remind us you know that
hey
uh you know i'm i'm a little bit
different than everybody else because
i have you know this code and i i really
feel bad about this because this guy
wasn't in the game and and and whatnot
and then they brought it back around in
this episode to have him do what he
think you know he thinks is right at the
moment which is go and give manuel varga
peace about you know the situation that
happened to his son
there's the obvious parallel there they
both lost the sun
um
mike believes that they're both good men
at their core and that he'll understand
this and then when he goes to the idea
of justice
you know it's it's really fascinating
because
manuel papa varga he tells him something
that that he
that he knows inside probably but he
can't really see or accept
and that's that you know there is no
justice in what he's doing he's just you
know he's just finding a way to continue
doing what he what he feels like he has
to do
and have it make sense and um you know
at the end of the day he's he's not
really that much different than the
people he's in and you know what i loved
about both of those scenes together was
it it just shows you
that you know there's really no escape
from this life you know what i mean this
life does it causes huge amounts of
problems for everyone close to these
people
and so to see mike sort of make it you
know sort of understand that in this
conversation that he that he's kind of
uh you know he's kind of full of it but
then still continue on throughout the
entirety of breaking bad
it really does change the way you think
about his character going forward
yeah they love to do these great visual
moments that act as sort of metaphors
for what's going on and there's one
moment in this episode that really
struck me in the scene you're talking
about where mike is speaking to manuel
right after manuel says you know you're
not talking about justice you're talking
about revenge right after he says the
word revenge it cuts to a side shot
where mike is behind a fence and manuel
is just in the foreground of the camera
so it appears like mike is in a prison
while manuel is free
and uh that to me was is the visual uh
metaphor for exactly what you're saying
that
mike is he calls them you're just a
gangster essentially and i think mike to
some extent realizes that's true
i can keep telling myself i'm a good
person inside but i'm living this awful
life
i'm part of a system that hurts people
and he essentially stays trapped in that
into breaking bad
and we see where it leads
yeah i kept thinking of in that scene is
the the line sangre por sangre uh
because that's essentially what mike's
doing here right that there's gonna be
more killing and if you go all the way
back to the beginning
it's all about max um
so you can see where all this starts
with the killing
and then the blood just keeps spilling
and we know that gus's thirst for
revenge which puts him in the room with
hector is what ends up blowing off half
his face and killing him so we don't
have to wonder if manuel is right we
know he is
yeah
and and i think you know the tragedy of
it is is that these characters know that
too
they they they fight against it just
like you do with anything that you don't
like about yourself you know what i mean
but it be because you have a you have
this place you're trying to get i mean
gus's is it you know gus is is i don't
know if it's more understandable but it
you know it's more
it's more in your face you know like
they killed my my
my lover and you know
now i'm going to
dedicate my life to getting
taking them all out you know getting my
revenge um
yeah it's it's
it's wild and like you said this this
scene with
to to know these characters for as long
as we have and then to get these little
scenes where they actually
make them they they actually add another
layer it's pretty amazing you know what
i mean like the
the gus scene i mean i i never really
thought it was a question of whether he
he was gay or not or max was his partner
i know they played coy with it but it to
me it seemed pretty
you know
self-evident that that's
he wouldn't be doing all he was doing if
there wasn't something more in that
relationship you know what i mean
and
you know to think that they could do
this and then and then just spin it a
little bit to show that that he's you
know he won't even give himself anything
like this this obvious setup for him to
you know to find uh romance right here
you know like obviously this is he's
turned on
they hit it off it's all going in the
right direction and then he pulls back
at the very end because it's just not
something that he'll allow himself to
experience
in pursuit of that goal you know what i
mean yeah it was that scene was so uh
striking it's just so unusual to see gus
legitimately smiling and not the fake
los poyo cermanos uh smile
uh yeah that's what i'm saying this is
like the first time we've ever seen that
in all of the years that we've watched
this character yeah and i think it's so
apropos right now towards the end of the
series to just remind us
that gus's story is also a tragedy he's
the guy who's in charge and he
is getting what he wants right he's
going after revenge and he nearly he
does get it but ends up taking his own
life but here they show us that he is
still capable of feeling something he is
still capable of having a human
connection with somebody that he's
making the choice to walk away from it
and like i was just saying before it's
so rare maybe not maybe more than rare
to see him genuinely smile and also to
sort of give himself up to somebody else
to watch him almost held captive by this
person's story and he's just smiling and
listening
once again it's seeing him not in charge
it's this whole other side to him it's
impossible to look away and then it's so
sad when he
his expression kind of drops and he sort
of decides all right back to work
all right um
there's a couple of other things that i
wanted to get into but we do have a few
super chats here so let's go ahead and
look at those
this first one i've been looking at for
a second and
i'm not really sure how to respond to it
uh thank you for the 499. do you think
saul's ibs will pop up later this season
like maybe he releases a massive fart in
the middle of a big case and blows it as
a result
um
i don't know about that specifically
but a cliffhanger moment right
yeah but what
yeah but but what uh i'm what i'm really
wondering at the end of this last
episode is what do the what i mean
obviously some of it's going to be in
the gene timeline
but
and some of it's going to be you know
will and or not will walt and uh jesse's
return
but yeah there's a lot of time that they
could be spending in
um
the better call salt timeline based on
what they have to work with and and it's
kind of hard to figure out what
might transpire there
do you guys have any ideas it was just
one or anything ibs related
we could circle back to that but one
just a clarifying point am i right that
we're still
even after that flash forward about
three years out from breaking bad just
based off the 2005 license plate
yeah that's the best information i saw
on it when i was doing my video
yesterday i couldn't
i couldn't find anything more concrete
than that and i just sort of avoided it
in in in the recap but i looked online
this morning for a second and it seems
to be the the consensus that it's
2005-ish
gotcha
the hair kind of throws me off but i
mean i guess that's that's what it is
you know yeah i guess it's it's such a
strange
it's so hard to speculate because it
feels like at this point
something new has to happen something we
don't know about unless there's another
flash forward in the next episode and
now we're in 2008 and we see walt and
jesse
so it feels like
there's got to be some story here
that is just something that's almost
unpredictable because it involves a new
story that doesn't necessarily have
threads in what we've already seen
uh i saw somebody mention it it feels
like a lot of the stories are wrapped up
at this point and it does feel that way
to me which is part of why it's so
exciting that we're entering this fresh
territory where it almost feels like
anything could happen
yeah i mean i think that the the mike
and um
mike and gus stuff it it totally felt
like the conclusion of their story you
know i mean in this in this timeline and
i don't really unless there's a good
reason for them to come back i don't
think we really need to see him again
and and like he said it's weird because
if he's in 2005 and at this point
then there is quite a bit of time that
they have you know to work with before
they even get to when uh walt and jesse
would make sense in 2008
right as i've always thought uh
up until this season i've always thought
hey maybe we get some kind of montage
that brings us through the break gets us
to the breaking bad timeline but at this
point it's hard for me to make a case
for why that'd be necessary because
really the only way i could see that
being useful is because it kind of shows
us saul goodman's life we get sort of a
flavor of his status quo until walt and
jesse show up
but between the cold open of this season
giving us a preview of this opulent
lifestyle and then even just the two or
three minutes we got the lat at the end
of last episode this one we're talking
about right now i feel like that did
such a great job of showing us who he is
which is basically jimmy mcgill has been
totally
buried underneath this saul goodman
persona
someone pointed out to me that even when
he's taking a shower he's already got
the bluetooth headset in almost like he
is just drowning out any possible moment
of private thought he is just on saul
goodman all the time and to me that that
almost told me everything i need to know
about who saul goodman is
so
yeah i guess this is a long way of
saying i'm not sure what story they have
to tell
before walt and jesse show up i'm sure
there's something
i'm excited to see what it is
yeah that'll be interesting i i i guess
i would like a little bit more
information about uh the struggle he's
gone through with uh with kim leaving
just a slight bit but like you said
that scene does a lot of heavy lifting
you know it's not about that but in some
ways it is all about that so
yeah i i'm with you it's
it's hard to see it
yeah i mean because i i haven't had a
chance to look at all the comments on my
on my video but i i was scrolling
through them a little bit earlier and um
i did see that a lot of people were like
oh this is you know this is
a terrible idea that we've been waiting
all this time to see the transition to
saul and now they just did it
in a heartbeat you know and i mean i i
don't agree with the uh
the point because i think if you really
think about it
they did explain so much about it you
know
not even verbally you know like it just
in the way that that it was it was
crafted and the way that you know the
things that they chose to show us and
you know i mean you do kind of have to
think a little bit about the um
the the episode one teaser where you
just saw him you know his his empty
mansion or whatever but
there's
i i t for me it it totally clicks and
this next question kind of feeds into
that uh james egan says uh thank you for
the australian 799 do you think saul is
now comfortable suggesting
sending people on a trip to belize by
the end of this episode
and i think what you're saying you know
what you guys are saying there is that
i don't know if he ever is comfortable
beyond the fact that he's just saying
what what what makes sense and he's and
he's really just this is all just
so that he doesn't have to live with the
reality of uh you know what what his
life has become what what what it is
after kim left and and what that means
so i don't know what do you guys think
can can he
does does he does he seem like he's
comfortable suggesting to send the
people you know send someone to belize
which is a big question and a lot of
people had for years because of that
that line and uh breaking bad
i think i think he's comfortable doing
just about anything um i i see a man who
doesn't really want to live any kind of
life um but he's got a life to live and
so he's just out there like doing
everything he can to take his mind off
the thing that's really annoying him
like i the thing you said that's that's
so interesting here is how non-verbally
they just communicate what's going on
inside his head like if you look at his
routine it's morning tonight it's if he
has not passed out in that
possibly rotating bed
he is doing something to distract
himself right he's got a prostitute that
he's hired to keep him company in the
evening all the way through the morning
breakfast until he's on the phone with
clients or other lawyers or francesca
he's then
opening the halls of justice and taking
in client after client after client
there is no break in his day
to even think about what he's lost um
yeah and just to just to interject for a
second and i was just before i forget
the fact that he has a giant bowl of
nutrigame bars on the the table that he
calls the breakfast bar i mean this is
an everyday occurrence for him you know
every single day yeah yeah
yeah they do such a great job with that
so yeah i think this is a man who
doesn't really care whether he lives or
dies at this point and
yeah sending somebody to belize is just
a tool for him right
yeah it's it's god and it you know
whenever you think about it
you know he was introduced as a funny
you know i always thought of saul
goodman as sort of a a shade of a comic
relief character you know to lighten the
mood because he was he was wacky
never again will i watch that that
show you know re-watch breaking bad and
and be able to to think about him in
that way yeah it's kind of just it's
just sad now
like it really is this opening scene or
not opening scene the end of the episode
of watching saul go about his day it
feels so over the top in a sense like
almost over acting
um but i and part of that's just because
we're so used to seeing the kind of saul
goodman prototype where it's a little
bit lower key
but i think that's that's intentional
where jimmy is putting on a show and now
that we know who he really is underneath
it starts to come off as sort of
superficial hollow
and to say the word again just sad
yeah that word sad was kicking around in
my head
for for all of them yesterday you know
kim man that's so sad
gus he's he's still he's still a you
know garbage human being psychopath but
what a sad story they they put there you
know mike sat you know that it it it was
it was the saddest of episode it does
make me wonder
i mean they almost there have there
almost has to be some sort of redemption
they sort of have to bring bring
this out of of this because i don't
really see him
ending on this this type of of a you
know
note for the for the finale of both
series together is that
in the end it was all really really sad
yeah it's been almost oppressively dark
the last couple of episodes
like uh point and what was the name of
the yeah point and shoot ended with us
burying lalo and um howard's bodies in
the super lab and it's so dark and just
it just you feel awful being in that lab
at this point and i almost feel like i
haven't left yet like going into this
episode it's still a very visually dark
episode with a few exceptions a lot of
it takes place at night with just mike
and manuel it just feels like this dark
lonely place
um so i feel like there's got to be
a couple bright spots left like with
mike you know you said earlier that
you'd be almost satisfied if we don't
see him again or we don't necessarily
need to see him again
i logically i don't necessarily see a
need to have mike show up again but
emotionally i kind of want to see him
with stacy and kaylee one more time
because the last time we saw them
interact you know was him calling
through the window while they were
looking at the stars and i want to see
one more moment of joy for him
knowing that he's only a few years out
from getting killed by walt um but yeah
it's your point it's just been so dark
is it gonna end this way or can we get a
happy ending i don't know
what do you what do you think about that
jim
i feel like there's a redemption coming
you think there's a shot that gene gets
some kind of redemption because that's
the only way i see it because we know
what what saul is
yeah
yeah this this next one which i see what
you do with your name there so i'm not
going to read it but thank you for the
499. um that this uh this is their idea
is that the gene teaser is him giving up
but not turning himself in going out
like
at davis in maine loud as hell and
flashy as saul
and i do think that that he will
he who will take one last turn and um
and really there's a lot of there's
there's a lot of possibilities to pull
on threads from from the entire series
with him doing one last you know
ridiculous scam in the gene timeline
but i also think that you know that that
that'll be the setup for the end rather
than the actual end
yeah in terms of what i would love to
see from gene is less any kind of
reverting back to a saw goodman persona
uh unless he uses it almost as a tool to
to
and maybe he needs to if he's if we're
going to get to this gene versus jeff he
needs to pull out some something from
his saw goodman tool belt but what i
would really like to see is some version
of redemption and i think part of that
is because with walter white in breaking
bad by the end of the series i kind of
felt like he
had a few redeeming qualities for sure
but at his core there were some rotten
things you know there was the pride and
ego as mike would say but with jimmy i
feel like his exterior is rotted to hide
there is something there at his core
which i like
and i think for a while he genuinely
wanted to do the right thing
and things went wrong so i haven't let
go of that part of him i like
and i would love there to be some sort
of redemption i don't know if that means
a happy ending but maybe it means a
bittersweet ending where at least he's
done something to make amends could he
call up you know howard's widow and tell
her a little bit of the truth of what
happened for example uh maybe confessed
to his role in what happened to chuck so
maybe things don't end well for him but
at least he's kind of unburdened himself
and tried to you can't write these
wrongs but at least do something
in that direction
all right mr g thank you for the five
dollars
they kind of wrapped up all the stories
any chance that that was the last major
part we see of the salt timeline and now
move on to gene's story
well
the only i i can see how you could
arrive at that idea and i think there's
definitely a possibility that we could
see a blending of the two
but we do know that you know aaron paul
and brian cranston are coming back and i
i saw something
yesterday that one of the major i can't
remember who was deadline hollywood or
one of those variety maybe was saying
that
they they confirmed that they will be in
the very next episode
so um
yeah i don't think it's going to go full
gene yet i i think that there should be
at least um
based on what's left i think there
should be at least two full gene scenes
or you know episodes but
you know they might just do a you know a
split you know like where they show
things in both timelines because they're
not really
you know there it's going to be more of
a you know a straightforward thing in
gene but maybe touching on some
different time periods like you know
because the time that we saw so far is
2005 and whatnot
have you guys been seeing the the after
episode little teaser things that that
yes
last week's yeah was um
you know jimmy saying like eventually
we'll forget all this we'll realize
we're healing
uh that thing and then this week you had
the mall
which was definitely desaturated like
gene
uh like his timeline the the interesting
thing about the last one was there was a
line from the beginning of the episode
right
uh where he he tells him like we'll
we'll forget about all this and start
healing
and it was accompanied by
the flash forward timeline in the image
of his
halls of justice
so i'm wondering if we'll get the same
thing from the next episode we'll get to
the line from earlier in the episode and
then the flash forward could happen at
the end to the gene timeline
hmm
interesting
yeah logistically that feels
like it could work because we've had so
few episodes left now so if they aren't
going to kind of jump back and forth
between the timelines it feels like by
the end of the next episode like we got
to start getting to that gene timeline
so we can properly
explore that and wrap it up
yeah i i do think there's a real
possibility that the next episode might
open with the with the gene teaser but i
don't you know they're they i know that
they're gonna go back and forth at least
to the point where they've been teasing
you know walt and jesse and that's going
to be more than just a short scene it
seems like so
yeah well i i i could i could go either
way i could go with completely linear or
you know keep us on our toes by jumping
around that would be fine with me too
jason king does not have a comment but
thank you for the twenty dollars i tried
to look down here there's
a follow-up statement here where he says
an idea i came up with recently we've
been worried the whole time about kim
dying
it's all gene going to die at the end of
the series
it's always a possibility but i i feel
like
i said a few minutes ago i feel like
they're setting him up for
because you know the question i keep
finding myself asking is
what's left of jimmy inside there you
know and um
we you know we talked about gus a little
bit
about how he he chooses to
deprive himself of
of the
of the life that you know he clearly
wants to have because he has this goal
you know that he that he wants to he
wants to get revenge and i i was
thinking about this sort of a parallel
with what's going on with jimmy and it's
not that he deprives himself as saul he
uses that as a coping mess mechanism is
what it appears like
and he and he and he indulges in
everything you know jimmy wasn't all
that indulgent
you know before and you know this guy
like we just said is you know he's he's
obviously
full-on uh you know he's he's talking
about xanax his xanax guy on the phone
and i mean he he's definitely
not he doesn't have very many
inhibitions holding him back from
just you know living life in the way
that he sees it
but i mean
he's also all of that requires him to
stuff down
who he really is you know he has to bury
jimmy to become that so you know he he's
he's kind of doing the same thing he's
depriving himself of that
jimmy life of being who he really is in
in pursuit of trying not to feel
the pain that is reality you know
yeah and i think um
as jimmy he was sort of
constantly rejected right chuck rejected
him and kim didn't really enter into a
relationship with him until he started
to show a little bit of his saul goodman
side
so
yeah i guess now as saul goodman he's
he's indulging and he has all these
people who
who are accepting him because they want
to use his services and use him to do
whatever
things whatever awful drug dealy type of
things they're doing
so
it's almost
i don't know i'm trying to draw i'm
thinking about him versus gus where it
does feel like they've both given up
similar things
where
jimmy can't really have a genuine
relationship with anybody the same way
gus can't
even though on the surface
jimmy does have plenty of relationships
with people but it's as saul goodman so
even when he's surrounded by people to
me he looks totally alone because yeah
they don't know jimmy
yeah to jump in just briefly you know
that
if you think about this
the time skip he went from a genuine
relationship to a
uh i don't know transactional i guess
right he's paying this this this woman
he's with to you know for her time to
stay with him
so that's that's pretty interesting too
when you think about it
true and i think it makes sense that
kim's rejection of fame would be the one
to push him over the edge because she
was almost like a stepping stone where
she did know the real jimmy but like i
was alluding to earlier the kind of
spark that ignited their relationship
was the slip and jimmy side and a little
bit of the saw goodman antics so she was
sort of the last
person that accepted
this
transitional version of jimmy saul and i
think her rejection
sort of pushes him over the edge where
he has to start looking for
companionship
on a like you said transactional level
yeah what i think when i hear this is
jimmy's been dead for multiple years now
right i mean here the gene timeline he's
been dead for
a decade uh or close to it
so
yeah i mean it's it's definitely
affected him
[Music]
devonte maurice thank you for the five
um nobody including kim wanted to get
into business with jimmy is saul
i'm only accepted for being a scumbag so
i'm going to embrace it
i think there's some of that in there
but i think there's maybe it's a little
more nuanced but
yeah i totally get this of like
you know that
his his drive is to be accepted you know
he wanted to be accepted by his brother
he wanted to be loved by his brother
it's sort of why he he he has that kind
of you know personality where he you
know he becomes everyone's friend you
know by doing
i don't know if it's like histrionic is
the right word but he sort of adapts
himself to whatever he's doing to try to
to make himself more likeable
to the people he is and of course
there's he's he's trying to gain an
advantage you know he he's
he uses it to manipulate people as well
but
you know deep down he i think that
they've been pretty
clear on saying that you know his his
his thing is that he wants to be loved
you know he
walder white wanted to have power he
wanted to be respected
jimmy is more about like he wants to be
accepted and loved and you know he's
been uh
he's had his heart broken a lot of times
at this point you know we sort of
watched that happen
but you know i think that yeah like if
you're getting that if you're getting
that through these channels i think you
were just sort of saying that gil too
you know if that if that's the way
you're getting that reinforcement
if that's what you really need then
that's where you go right right and i
think we see that positive reinforcement
throughout the series
and not only do we see positive
reinforcement where we see
one of the only people who
really
respects jimmy
early on was marco and that was only
when jimmy and marco were pulling scams
together and then the next episode the
opener to season two
again when jimmy and kim finally
start a real relationship it's after
they pull a scam together and even
recently
when jimmy went to the courtroom and he
was a total pariah then he comes back to
the better call saul office and he's
totally accepted there but on the other
side of it we also get negative
reinforcement for trying to do good and
that a lot of that came from chuck where
jimmy at least thought that he was
genuinely on a path toward doing the
right thing but chuck never believed him
so trying to do the right thing screwed
him over but doing the wrong thing
everybody loves me so i think that's
definitely a variable here
you want to add anything jim
yep good
all right um rod kiefer thank you for
the 4.99 with no kim
why should we care about walt jesse or
marion and marion is referring to the
caribbean carol burnett character that
we didn't get to meet yet um
with no kim why should we care about
walt disney or marion well i mean
kim is a very important
part of the story but it is it is jimmy
mcgill's story
and um
i
they they they've done a pretty good job
of only bringing back characters
whenever it serves the story when it
makes sense for for what's happening so
i think we'll care about walt jesse and
or marion because
it will tell us something that we didn't
already know about this character jimmy
mcgill
saul goodman
yeah it needs to i'm i'm not super
thrilled with you know fan services
stuff most of the time um i felt like
even early on in this series they leaned
into that a little bit hard for me with
the tuco stuff
but
if they're just gonna bring walt and
jesse back to say hey we brought walt
and jesse back
it's not going to do it for me
no and i mean i think they've been
pretty
but
yeah i think they've been pretty vocal
about that they're excited about it and
they think it makes sense at least
and i i i you know i trust them
especially after this episode yeah i'm
definitely like just show me what you
got let's see what you see what you came
up with
yeah it is funny um jim i remember
watching that first episode and all the
interviews leading up to it we're we're
not going to just throw in a bunch of
fan service cameos then the end of the
episode was like tuko opens the door and
looks around and i kind of rolled my
eyes at it and then i loved the episode
that followed and loved what they did
with it so it kind of bought my trust
back
and then they've shown such restraint
since then the fact that walt and jesse
aren't showing up until now i mean even
the fact that we were living with jimmy
mcgill and not saul goodman for so long
i i'd love to believe and i do believe
that it's not going to be a fan service
cameo
but i mean to rod's point here
i don't think we necessarily know why
we're going to care but i believe
they're going to give us a good reason
too
yeah
seth
bjernerkemper
bjonerkemper
thank you for the 20 that's very
generous
i really love the context that they gave
to mike and gus this episode peter gould
said when asked if he could give
con
contact
contact what is that word
context i think yeah for the episode
that mike would go darker and gus would
find love
was this it will there be more and no i
i do believe that this is exactly um
what he was talking about whenever he
did those
in the preseason i think this was
it was uh the the gus finding love thing
i don't think that they'll be
expanding on i mean they could but it
would feel a little tacked on after they
did it so perfectly right here
at least for my opinion um
mike could go darker uh
he's in he's in a pretty dark place
right now
but like i said i think it just sort of
connects with what we were just talking
about i don't think that they should
bring them unless it has something to do
like i don't think they need to do
anything more with those characters
specifically
gill was under the impression that it
would be nice to see
a moment of joy for for mike and i i
don't disagree with that i think that
would be cool
but um
you know i think that if they if they if
they do
mike is i think a little bit different
because the show is somewhat about mike
as well like he's he's more of a main
character than gus
you know gus is an important character
but you know we actually followed mike
and you know he had his own he had his
own narrative throughout the the
series so
um
yeah i don't know do you have any you
guys have anything extra you want to add
to this
i mean if they tried to give gus uh
another love interest now
i don't know there's enough time to do
much justice to that and what i don't
want is a scenario where we leave this
series with
questions like we had about kim like
where's kim is she in the background
during breaking bad like
why don't we ever see her you know i
wouldn't want to see that with like a
gus love interest because because that
could just be a never answered question
yeah that's true i didn't think about
that but that is that is a real obstacle
to having him do anything like that
because
he definitely didn't there were no signs
of that in in the original series
okay um
kevin sweiber thank you for the five
dollars what is the big white building
in call and saul's car window reflection
in fast forward
it really stood out even caught his eye
for a couple of secs um
i i don't know i didn't i didn't i mean
i saw that there was some some
i thought it stood out like i didn't
really
dwell on it but i did think it's it was
weird seeing him drive around in the car
that it seemed more like it it didn't it
almost seemed like he was in a new place
but he he was in albuquerque as far as i
know right
i think so yeah they seem like they it
seemed like we saw like just a little a
different
a different look at albuquerque there
but i i don't know anything about the
city myself do you guys know this uh
this big white building any any
idea
nope
sorry kevin
yeah sorry kevin i don't i i
i did like i said notice that it was it
looked a little different but i have no
i've never been to albuquerque so i i
don't have any context beyond that
mike d thank you for the 5 canadian
end of episode 9 saul accepted
public exposure case same offense he
mixed up for badger when meeting him
i think the current timeline now is
season 2 episode 8 of breaking bad well
a lot of people were saying this
yesterday and
one thing i know for sure you know this
shirt that he's wearing
is you know that that we see in this uh
you know in the in the fast four that
that is definitely not what he's wearing
on the day whenever um
he goes to meet with badger so
i do believe that it you know people had
pointed out the the license plate tag
that makes sense to me um
they have made mistakes before though at
the same time you know that a lot of
times you hear people saying they never
make a mistake everything's for a
purpose but
i think if you really look at it
objectively these guys have had a couple
uh mistakes like that before so i i
don't know
um but i i don't think that the
the public masturbator comment was more
than like it you know it makes us think
about that but i don't think it's
directly relating to
uh brandon mayhew
he also says another one of these so you
get the impression there are many of
these cases so uh so i think when it
happens to badger that's just
one in a long line that he gets probably
on on a daily basis
the fifi one was the guy the old man was
that was what his deal was too wasn't it
yeah i know he was some sort of a sex
offender i don't recall if they said
what exactly the offense was
but that would make sense
yeah so it maybe it's an ongoing thing
it to me that almost sounds like after
the the the giant testicles thread that
almost sounds like uh
thomas snow's uh influence that's right
yeah
matt pollikin
fournette
thank you very much like the kimark it
explains why saul isn't totally broken
we all we have all experienced
heartbreak but it's something to
overcome not like her dying
um
yeah um
i i don't know i mean
we you know before there was this idea
that he couldn't be the the soul that we
we knew in breaking bad be so happy go
lucky
if kim died um i don't think that they i
i think they recontextualized that
rather than
uh you know proved it because of what
happened you know what i'm saying like i
think he's equally devastated in some
ways that she's still out there and that
she just decided to leave his life you
know what i mean it it wasn't some
tragedy that he can move on from it's
something you know where he can always
think what what did i do wrong how could
i have done that different um
and
when i say they recontextualized it i
mean they showed that he's he's just
throwing himself into being this
happy-go-lucky uh you know crazy um
you know criminal lawyer so that he
doesn't have to experience that just the
same way he did you know he he started
this process after chuck died you know
what i mean he he he said hey look
i'm not going to be jimmy mcgill anymore
because that name's burned i'll always
be chuck's you know loser brother and
and so his solution for that to not
think about how awful chuck dying made
him feel and he had that same
responsibility he knew on some level
that he was responsible for what
happened
uh you know he started this process and
now it's just like turned up to 11.
yeah i would just add that the
it's heartbreak but they've also shown
us that it's it's an especially painful
heartbreak for jimmy because i think he
sort of put all of his eggs in the kim
wexler basket she was sort of the last
fit last personal connection left for
him especially with his close friend
marco gone
um he was so horribly rejected by chuck
and then was partially responsible for
pushing chuck over the edge so it's not
simple heartbreak it's also i think he
walks away from the kim experience
saying
i will never be accepted the only way i
can be accepted is by throwing myself
into this saul goodman creature
yeah
it feels a lot like severance
except
all is who he is when he's severed
right right
and and there really isn't his life when
he's not separate right it's when he's
sleeping so he can't really affect
um
yeah it it is a little like a light
switch like just flipping the switch
yeah and that was also um motivation for
i freaking mark was that the main
character's name in severance
yeah so for him he was also dealing with
trauma and what helped him deal with it
was well if i just switch to a different
personality when i'm at work that's part
of something i just drink all the time
when i'm at home right
yeah
that really is a pair i hadn't thought
about that at all i liked that gym i
hadn't i didn't hadn't made that
connection but
mark and saul do have some things in
common there
let's see here alex thank you for the
five dollars could the license plate be
a red herring i mean he has a vanity
plate
and i could see him just not renewing
the plates
it seems closer to breaking bad
yeah it's like i said they it could just
as easily be a mistake you know i
wouldn't put too much um
i i don't know i would just say let's
wait and see because you know
it doesn't really make a big difference
until we find out how the story is going
to shape up anyways
i don't think it's i don't think they
would i don't think that they would uh
to answer your question specifically
alex i i don't think that they would do
that on purpose like uh you know sleight
of hand like
we'll make
this put this date on this plate just to
confuse everyone i don't i don't see i
don't see what they accomplished by
doing that right that'd be i think too
subtle of a twist to next episode like
you thought it was 2005. but actually
it's 2007
two few people who were paying enough
attention to notice a license plate
which was not me at least not until my
second viewing
yeah that's some westworld stuff yeah
does that very much
yeah uh
yeah i've been listening i've been i've
been i've been just to do a little uh
a little breakaway for a second um i
i've been i've been i've been really i
did i was done with westworld you know
like i kind of
i kind of quit it and then i i was like
in the first few episodes of the season
so i've been listening to your
you're in a ron's uh podcast jim because
i'm not gonna do it i'm not gonna go and
reread it for hours again you know what
i mean like i've been burnt if they come
back around maybe i'll do it again later
but um yeah just enjoy the show just
watch the show and have fun with it
yeah absolutely that's a lesson that you
know it it it has it has other
applications you know what i mean
because
one of the things i was thinking about
you know
the trickiness because like we were
talking earlier there's so many endings
in this
and um peter gould i think it was in the
in the insider podcast he was he was
talking about the
you know not knowing how it was going to
end and and how in a way that's a relief
sometimes because when you have that
ending in mind
you hold on to it it's hard to hold on
to for for years i mean this show's been
on for a long time now you know
and i was thinking about that with you
know the way that it's kind of
finding ways to surprise us and do new
things even though you know there's been
all these ideas of how these inevitable
things would happen
and you know it's like
if you think about it you know like
to have that have the idea of like say
kim was going to go to prison
how much that's changed you know
by letting the characters do what what
makes sense for them instead of writing
to that outcome you know what i mean
so
one of the things about the you know
westworld and and shows that are you
know that are that really reward that
kind of
and and better call salt too because
it's a prequel and there's so many
references to the original
one of the bat you know one of the the
bad parts of that is that you you find
things in your when you're looking and
you get attached to them and then you
know it kind of paints what actually
happens in in you know in a different
light and kind of takes away the
enjoyment on some levels
so i agree with you that you know with
what's going on with that show is like
i'm enjoying it a lot more when i'm not
like obsessing over the details that are
going on for sure so may so maybe that
maybe that fits in a little bit with
that license plate question
so it's not a complete uh
derailment of the train
summit traffic's 9.99 thank you very
much uh after this episode it's brutal
to go back and watch how jay and kay
treated howard for coming clean
re his role in chuck's death
love to hear your contract
the love to hear you contrast those
scenes with this episode
yeah howard for coming clean i
i don't you say jane kay that's throwing
me off a little bit but yeah it's um
he's talking jimmy
well i think it's when howard uh when he
comes to jimmy and kim and basically
says i went to chuck and sort of forced
him into retirement i think i may have
driven him to do what he did
and uh i think he committed suicide and
jimmy says that's your cross to bear
yeah
that's what i'm saying though that was
that was fully jimmy like kim didn't
really back him up or oh she's just kind
of like she was kind of like couldn't
believe what she was seeing either at
the time right
yeah yeah i agree with that yeah later
and just chews into him for that
yeah so um
yeah i mean
that's a very complicated scene you know
because
it's not clear
especially when it first aired like now
my my
i've kind of like mellowed on it um
when i first watched it i was like is he
doing that like does he see an angle
here like that he can play against um
you know this situation like he can
actually
you know show you know use howard as as
the scapegoat for this like to you know
because he just goes over and he feeds
the fish and and he just sort of moves
on you know what i mean like oh okay
well that's across the bear
now i think that there was you know it's
more of a
an inability to to process what's
happening
so much not so much like he just wanted
you know he's like oh well i'm off the
hook i'm ready to go feed the fish
well and specifically so that was
actually also the moment where jimmy
learns that he was even more responsible
than he realized because jimmy had gone
into the insurance office and told them
about chuck's breakdown in court they
raised the premiums which is what caused
howard to push chuck into retirement so
howard
mentions the insurance issue to jimmy
and up until that point in the episode
jimmy was basically catatonic barely
talking and he goes the insurance
and and howard tells him they were
raising the insurance and at that moment
jimmy just transformed suddenly he's all
smiles he's whistling he's feeding the
fish so to me it always felt like or at
least looking back on it it felt like as
soon as jimmy is confronted with this
guilt that he's responsible for this he
kind of shoves it down it's sort of a
prototype for saul goodman yeah it's a
mini
it's a mini saw move exactly exactly
yeah so that's
i mean i i understand what the the the
question is asking
um
oh sorry go ahead
no you can go ahead i'm still forming an
idea here yeah i was going to say this
did just seeing this question
specifically made me think of one scene
from this episode
where um
is it cheryl is that howard's wife yeah
wait [ __ ] when they say
yeah when they speak with cheryl
and and she's trying to make sense of
what happens
and kim lies to her
that felt almost
equally cruel as jimmy's saying you know
this is your cross to bear and i just
it feels like such an injustice in this
series the hamlets both of them are so
horribly treated
and to even see it up until now in this
moment
and that's one moment i would love to
get your guys's thoughts on is just why
did kim choose to say that
but both make me anytime i think of
howard or cheryl
i just i just it turns my stomach to
just see how horribly treated they've
been throughout the series
especially i'll just do a couple more
things on that but just howard was such
an interesting character where we never
got to see much of his personal life we
would sort of just check in on him every
once in a while there's a certain period
of time on the show where i kind of
forgot about howard a little bit and
then you see him and he's just ragged
he's suffering from insomnia and then
jimmy has that great line i gotta ask
what's eating ya and so we just see
these little flashes of this character
we see the namaste license plate so just
in minutes if you put a screen time
together you get this entire journey of
howard
facing up to the fact that he may have
pushed one of his closest friends into
killing himself watching him
suffer watching him come to some kind of
reconciliation with that only to get
pulled into this scam and then killed
it's it's sickening yeah
yeah the stuff with his wife and kim is
particularly brutal and i think kim does
it because she knows it'll work is is
the truth of it yeah like
this is the lie that i need to tell and
this is
this is the worm that i need to use to
get into this woman's head to make her
believe
the lie that we're spinning um 100 agree
let her hang herself here you know just
give give her enough rope and then and
then when she looks to cliff cliff is
gonna
you know be cliff and not not confirm it
publicly but like
all but confirm it right um
she just knows it'll work and it's
brutal it's absolutely brutal but she's
doing what she's got to do in that
moment to sell the story and she's
surgical surgical in some ways
yeah absolutely
yeah no i think it was right it's so
hard to stomach the idea that even after
everything they went through with howard
she even has it in her to tell that lie
but
as much as kim is suffering right now
and dealing with this trauma she is
still that person that when something
needs to be done if she was willing to
go to this random stranger's house pull
out a gun and shoot him
she can tell this lie
yeah and i think i think what you know
i'm glad you brought this up because no
one else has really mentioned it in the
questions and it's the turning point too
right i mean she
she does it she knows that she could
continue to do it
it basically proves that if she wanted
to she could stick with this life and
and continue to to to get away with the
lie she's that good you know
and she makes this up on the spot you
know this isn't a planned thing you know
and and
jimmy's a pro
at doing this sort of thing and you know
they you know she's able to step in and
and just deliver like what you said jim
exactly what needs to be said and
and and it's just so
i mean
it's dirty you know like she she uses
you know this situation against a
grieving woman who just lost her husband
you know it's it's fascinatingly bad and
um it just took him from her too it's
the worst yeah it's their fault
yeah
that's that's horrible uh and you you
know the poison comes into play here
right because jimmy sets this up and she
knocks it down
it's it's this tag team
play that they do that's so
vicious
that just keeps hurting people
and you're right gil that's when they
see it that's when she notices
yeah this this is very bad we've gone
too far here and we're going to keep
doing it because i think also in her
head she's saying
i just got away with this i just nailed
that pitch
and that was a thrill for me too
mm-hmm
it's so because doing anything good is
is satisfying like it you know if you're
if you're that good at something how can
you not be like damn you know i i
i can't believe that one so well
in light of the gravity of the situation
you know it's it's it's a great i mean
it's such a great uh
the way that they wrote this is just
amazing but like i said i do think that
this is the moment like by the time they
go back out into the parking garage and
they have that kiss
i believe there she's already made up
her mind that she's leaving you know
like this is the this is the point where
she says and it's and it's in contrast
with what mike does whenever he gets the
information from manuel that that it
never ends
mike gets the idea that it never ends
and he says okay but you know i got this
thing i got to do so this is you know
this is my path
and she says if i keep doing this we're
so good at this and you know it's never
going to end there's always going to be
a reason to keep com you know things are
just going to keep happening and we'll
never be able to get away from it
yeah and i thought a lot after the
episode about what that kiss was and i
think pete you're right that at that
point she realized i need to leave jimmy
the two of us which is almost the wrong
way to phrase it because it's she
doesn't
in her mind the two of them should not
be together she does want to be with him
but she recognizes objectively we are
poison when we're together
um saying that she left him almost makes
it sound a little bit more selfish than
it is
and i think in that moment she wasn't
ready to say it necessarily so the best
she could do is just
it's almost like conciliatory kiss i
just i want to tell you i don't know
what to say i don't have the words for
it i care for you
so so i'll kiss you i'll show you
it's not it's not exactly the right
sentiment but this reminded me of the
godfather when uh michael kisses fredo
it's like
yeah
this is a goodbye right this is a
i i
i know what has to be done here and this
is the end
yeah and i i thought you know when i did
my video i thought that
uh it's
there's the point like yeah
she's decided and then what what
confused me a little bit was why she
withdrew from the bar initially but i
think you know that is
that just sort of drives it home you
know that she that this thing was kind
of drawn it was kind of it kind of came
from her idea that she should just she
should decide who deserves justice and
and help to
use these scamming powers with jimmy to
to kind of
tip the scales and so you know her her
pulling out from the bar that that's her
saying that i shouldn't have anything to
do with
you know
matters dealing with justice and and it
makes me want it makes me worry a little
bit that she's just going to have this
life where she's punishing herself for
what's happened you know in contrast to
jimmy not ever being able to to look at
it
yeah i kind of last night when i was
talking about this episode i was sort of
thinking out loud
how
i would love for kim to just leave this
life behind and at its core i mean she
loves being a lawyer she's like you were
saying pete when you're really good at
something it kind of creates a passion
for it but at its core she wanted to
help people and working in the law is
not the only way to do it so i would
love for her to find another way to help
the people who need it and get some kind
of a happy life now that she's left bad
choice road
and a couple people countered that by
saying
she doesn't deserve it because she still
has not
owned up to her role in what happened to
howard and deserve is one variable right
that's not necessarily the way the the
world works or sometimes this story will
go out of its way to give people what
they deserve but not always
and there's also the complicating factor
that
if she does come clean and reveal what
happened with lalo and everything that
potentially puts her in the crosshairs
and that could get her killed and the
you know the punishment should fit the
crime right execution is not the the
right outcome for her either so you know
sometimes it's a messy ending um
but yeah i would love to believe kim
could go out there and find some other
way to to get fulfillment in life
outside the law
i mean within the law you know not
breaking the law but outside of working
in the legal profession
yeah
i think one of the other reasons she
gives up her law license here is because
it's kind of a point of no return i i
think
i wonder in her head she she's thinking
well if i go back to this apartment
and i let and i talked to jimmy about
this i might end up changing my mind but
if i go through with this before i tell
him before he knows and before we have a
conversation then i can just make it
final before we even have to consider it
yeah that's a good point because he that
was his initial hey let me go get the
printer we're going to get this to stay
up all night and order pizza because
we need to be together
yeah
yeah he tried
he did definitely try
seth bu
bunner kemper thank you for the five
dollars again um i'll probably murder
your name if you decide to do that again
i apologize for that
anyone think we would see walt
and or jesse at the end of the episode
in saul's office for a major cliffhanger
payoff even if it's just on the phone
um
i don't know i i thought that that was
that was possible it felt like it would
be a little bit um
structure wise it seemed like it would
be like tacking something extra on the
end that after like such a like what
felt like at least in my experience like
a flawless
episode as far as the way they set
things up but it felt like an
unnecessary step like you know where you
can bring that in and and really
showcase that in the next episode but
any time when you go every time when you
see that um
you know the the uh constitution behind
him in that room
it always feels like that could that
could happen i think
yeah i mean nothing really to add
besides i had the exact same thought
it's impossible not to say is this where
it happens are they going to show up
but that may have been uh a good example
of them showing the restraint and saying
not yet we're not quite there yet
don't worry it's coming
we're definitely
you know definitely told you that but
at the beginning of the season so you'd
be looking for it everywhere but
you know it looks like we're finally
going to get to it uh sue's b art thank
you for the 499. do they divorce before
sandpiper pays off
so saul gets all the money
what do you think about this jim
well i mean the first half of that
question is a good question on its own
do they divorce
um
i don't know
they'll probably want to make it
official i suppose but
uh
i i don't know saul's gonna get all the
money i assume he gets a lot of money
based on what his house looks like yeah
uh i assume a lot of that sam piper
money is going toward
that that mcmansion in the middle of uh
albuquerque
uh with the marble floors and the roman
uh pillars and stuff
so yeah he probably gets a good chunk of
it if not all of it
do you think kim would be like i don't
want any of that money it's dirty money
that's what i was thinking yeah
now that we're talking about this uh
there there is one thing i'm curious to
get you guys to weigh in on
the the the flash forward in episode 405
uh you know he he talks about this call
that's coming in on his birthday
he tells um
why am i blanking on uh francesca yeah
francesca
that you know she'll be there at that
time on his birthday to get this call
and um
i've always thought that was kim
does does this mean
okay so i still do
i still think it's kim and so
that would mean that they still have
some connection you know they still talk
on some level so what do you guys think
yes or no
we could have used one more line from
kim before she stormed out of the room
i'm never speaking to you again except
once a year on your birthday i'm gonna
call you
but i could see her you know one lonely
night drinking a glass of zafiro on yejo
and you know she thinks of jimmy and
just calls him on his birthday to wish
him a happy birthday
i i
i could see it i mean i definitely think
it's a possibility
i i'll say i don't think we've seen the
last of kim i think that if there is
some kind of redemption and some kind of
gene looking back on his life and trying
to make sense of it
i feel like kim's gotta figure into that
and maybe they they meet again
when jimmy has more clarity and and
understands why she left
um and there could be some great
conversation there
yeah yeah i could see just an hour an
episode it's an hour-long phone call
between the two on his birthday
honestly i bet they can make that
entertaining i would love that side it
could be a
like a bonus podcast episode audio only
yeah the jeez i mean that that just i
don't know why but just right in that
part of this conversation i i just was
like damn it's coming to an end isn't it
it really is winding down there's only a
few more few more of these weeks left um
but yeah i don't think we can say for
sure about the the to get back to the
question about
that i i think there was a deleted scene
from breaking bad where he said that he
had three ex-wives
i know that you know there's a comment
about his second wife which we know
that's before
he was married to kim they they did
you know clear that they did make that
clear when they got married and um
i don't know if that other one counts
because like i said it's it's from uh
it's from uh like a dvd extra it wasn't
it never actually showed up in one of
the breaking bad episodes
all right
robert thank you for the ron 10
ron 10. the weirdness of kim's name is
still important um
i never thought it was
i never really bought into that theory
have you ever did either you guys ever
uh
think about this idea that she didn't
have a middle name
lots of people don't have middle names
right
yeah neither my parents have middle
names
yeah i mean that's sort of the way that
i i
there was a big thing about it i think
it was a popular theory um
that it was proof you know that that she
was living under an assumed identity do
you think there still is room for a
swerve like that that she wasn't kim all
along and and that would make sense and
and because like you said i do expect
her to come back and i do think that
there's real potential for her
not just to show up back in jimmy's life
but to see some of her life in the way
we see jean scenes you know
but i i don't know that i don't know
that any of those those theories about
her really really hold up anymore you
know i feel like it's pretty they i
think i feel like they told us here that
it was it's pretty straightforward you
know there's not they're not really
keeping too many secrets from us
there's stuff we don't know about her
just like there's stuff we don't know
about gus's past in chile but you know
for the most part we can we can believe
what we've seen as far as what the
character's done
so i don't expect that name thing to
come back up all right space king thank
you for the five dollars has anyone
mentioned that kim didn't mention
divorce are they still married
well we were just talking about that and
um
it's a big question
i don't know
yeah i feel like in that moment she just
wanted to
that that was kind of the logistics of
what happens next were very secondary to
making it clear why she's leaving and
then leaving before like you were saying
earlier pete you know she doesn't want
to have a risk of changing her mind or
anything that's why she notified the bar
i am if i had to predict logistically
what happens next i would imagine she
may maybe she tries to get the divorce
but it's done
with as little contact between them as
possible you know
using cheryl as their attorney
yeah there you go
that would be
that would be something
i mean i'm down for having uh
the actor come back i mean
she did a great job like she was like in
in maybe what five minutes of screen
time in the entire series and
just a hundred percent
howard hamlin's wife
that we never knew about
and now we know so much about you know
what i mean like it's just a great uh
interjection of a side character there
trustee thank you for the five dollars
something has to happen to make kim go
into hiding
no need to make secret call on public
phone one times a year if not on the run
but now we're we are in
breaking bad timeline thoughts um well i
was thinking about this when we were
just talking about you know the other
question
and i think that that you could answer
that by her just not wanting jimmy to
know where she's at
you know wanting to be able to check in
on him
but do it in this anonymous way where he
can't come looking for her or he can't
come and and try to you know
get him put himself back into her life
what do you guys think
yeah i would think that the barrier
there would be emotional certainly um
that that's the distance she's keeping
and why it would be once a year not not
because like it logistically doesn't
work out just because
it's all she can really bear
yeah
yeah second that to totally agree
um
let's see what we got here uh thank you
for that question
mattia
matthias
munchmeyer
clp2500
i feel like gus weinstein would have won
some
would have won some layers if the wine
had been chilean
the wa the waiter talking about a trip
to chile nostalgia for gus
yeah that would have been
you know
i think maybe that they would not do
that just because they don't plan to
ever really reveal what happened there
so they don't want to kind of rub it in
our nose like hey you know that one
thing you don't know about
gus has passed back in the pinochet
regime well we're not going to be
telling you any more about that either
but hey you know here's a little
reference to it just to
annoy you or whatever i think it would
have been distracting in the same way of
if they were certain if he was like i'll
have a bottle of zafiro anejo you know
you would suddenly start to think well
what are they trying to tell us you know
and i think this scene wasn't about
gus's past um so to you know to have us
thinking about that it might send us on
um a chase for clues that aren't there
yeah i mean i think we've talked about
this several times on the stream before
but
i think we've all said that we're okay
with not ever knowing more about his his
past
is that where you're at on that too jim
or
are you dying to know
what his violent past in chile was i
mean i would love to know but i'm also
okay with it not happening i will say if
they ever did another spin-off on this
universe at any time in the future
uh i would love to see either gus's
background in chile or
lalo perhaps
you know it's interesting i remember
listening to your podcast and you and
your wife were mentioning that that was
your first choice of of a of a spin-off
like pretty quickly you you went into
and i and i don't know i was
i think what this episode did
with this scene in particular was it
kind of re it kind of rekindled my
interest in the character
um you know i i kind of there was a
there was a point in the series where i
was just kind of like okay well we have
to we have to do this gus stuff you know
like of course uh we need to you know it
needs to keep moving but i wasn't all
that compelled with
the new layers that we saw until we got
to this one just because
you know it kind of it kind of made all
the other stuff make more sense you know
i mean it made it richer by by adding
something like that because before i
just thought it made him darker and
you know like he was already pretty dark
you know he was already pretty menacing
so
i i do i think i like the long story
short i guess i do agree that it would
be a good uh
prequel if they if they went back into
his life somewhere yeah i don't think
they'll ever do it but if they did i
would i would watch
absolutely
you have a you have a if you had if you
thought of a a uh a prequel what would
it be gil
uh so i think i i feel like it would
start to feel a little claustrophobic if
we continue to focus on these characters
we're already familiar with and we're
continuing you know if we go further
into the past and we're like okay at
what point does gus meet max and when do
we get into the breaking bad flashback
timeline so i would want to get i would
love something in this universe that's
maybe only tangentially related um the
one i've always thrown out is the vet
i just the vet is such a fun character
to me we know nothing about that
character so um to me then i could have
my cake and eat it too we're in this
universe it's tangential to all this but
he could tell his own whole you know
separate story
or something totally new a character
we've never met before
yeah that that's a good that's a good
one um
it would be weird if they just did
something
completely unrelated and i i don't
really think i mean it doesn't seem like
peter or vince have interest in it
i do wonder if they might you know amc
has said that they want a show i do
wonder if they might try to um
wrangle one of the staff writers into
into something but um
yeah i i don't really i mean it
i didn't really think after game of
thrones that they would come up with
like eight new shows either
so i mean it's kind of like the time
we're in you know where that that might
just be unavoidable in a way um you know
but uh
nothing really
nothing really seems crucial a lot of
stuff that could be really cool like you
like you know those some of the side
characters and things and
even gus or you know kim whenever she
was younger but um
none of it seems necessary yeah big
ralph thank you for the five um
nobody gets no one gets away
scot-free no more mike slash gus
jimmy is dead
kim is bcs version of jesse
getting away but not really getting away
false end for kim
yeah i don't disagree with any of that
um
it's not really a question it's more of
a statement but
i'm with you yeah she's paid a very high
price
for the fun she had you know
she she
that fun came to an end she lost uh
the person she loves
she's got uh
uh being complicit in the murder of
someone that she liked
um there's a lot there
she's done a lot of bad to a lot of
people and i think that's gonna weigh on
her
yeah and like i said i i don't i think
that's another thing that that that
flash forward did it it refocused on um
it refocused on uh
his character on jimmy and saul and it
it did she you know it does make you
wonder like where does where does she go
you know it's not clear
it's just clear that she needs to get
away but but what she does
as far as like
how she reacts to that
is a really big question
because like you said jim there's a big
cost that went into it
michael d thank you for the five i think
we may get 105 scene with kim as she
decides to leave albuquerque for good
makes peace with jimmy and sets up the
birthday call
you know i didn't really think about
that
i assumed that she was taping up boxes
because she was leaving leaving town
right then um
i mean she she she
she quit the bar and she
i don't know what what would keep her in
albuquerque
you know
but what do you guys think is it
possible that she still stays around for
a year after that last scene we saw
i don't think that's the case but it is
possible that maybe we see that first
birthday call you know at some point you
feel like it's got to get how do they
come back to that how do they explain
who that is and one way to do it would
be
show us the first instance of it or
maybe in one of the once we're into the
breaking bad timeline we see that even
then you know saul's getting that call
once a year and for a moment lets his
guard down and he's the real jimmy you
know for five minutes
um so i think that's possible
but i do think i read it the same way
she's packing up she's leaving town
a birthday call like that um
i like what you said about you know
seeing the real jimmy for a second
because that further reinforces
the reason he saw
um they did
yeah though what you said about earlier
pete about it then ver non-verbally
telling us all that stuff
it could then reinforce everything they
did this episode
yeah
really like the uh
the reference to the old um
garbage can there you know i was gonna
mention that actually because i feel
like a lot of people have mentioned in
the comments so this felt like a series
finale in some ways a lot of the
characters feel like they came to some
conclusions but it also had a few of the
sort of tropes that you would see in a
series finale one of them being call
backs to the first episode like jimmy
kicking that trash can and then now in
the finale he notices oh they've
replaced it or the saying goodbye to a
very familiar location so hhm we're all
in there for the last time they're
moving to another office changing the
name or even just the
getting a bunch of supporting characters
together for almost a goodbye to sing
schweitkart seeing cliff seeing all
these people brought together and
there's audio too
yeah that's right yeah and even there it
was almost a reunion because it's it's
so rare to see all those salamancas
together so just these different
gatherings there were these
trademarks of tv that really made this
feel like a finale
yeah i agree 100 it was a series finale
in a way um but it's it happens to be
a series that is a prequel and is
actually been
teasing what's going to a sequel at the
same time you know what i mean so
there's there's multiple timelines at
play but the bcs one does feel like it's
been concluded right
ninoy gobb thanks for the california or
the uh canadian five
they didn't wrap up everything do you
think they will ever shed light on who
gus was and his story with the madrigal
ceo
i don't
like we just talked about this and um
that's a
that peter schuller
they did bring him back in season five
it's kind of hard to think about how
they might shoehorn that into what's
left
either you guys see a path to that
no i think the fact that you use the
word shoehorn kind of
that tells me the way i think about it
too it just doesn't it doesn't feel
necessary to me at this point because
that doesn't necessarily further the gus
character arc it's almost more just
filling in details that i don't think we
necessarily need
and it just feels like limited real
estate left for the series so i i don't
think we'll see it but i mean he was
almost a perfect character like they
didn't even need to bring him back like
he one of the one of the best one
episode
uh arcs of all time you know what i mean
yeah
do you have anything with that jim uh
yeah i mean similar to the way
that we really loved the time jump from
kim breaking up with jimmy to him being
saul
in 2005.
i think they've done a great job leaving
gus in a place where
you just see him going to breaking bad
from here um
you know he's had he's had that moment
where he could have made a different
choice and then we see him make the
choice to cut everyone else off from his
life
and be that guy so
yeah i'm i am perfectly happy where they
left gus i don't need any more with him
at all in this series um
that said i do still think there's
plenty of time to tell story here
i just don't think it does
i agree i agree
big ralph thank you for the five so the
carol burnett rumor was the producers
pulling the biggest prank on their fans
in tv history
also episode nine is a false ending for
kim
um
carol burnett rumor it's not a rumor
there she's definitely going to show up
in the next couple of episodes uh they
announced that on the official
uh amc stuff
um there was a there was a guy who was
like an industry insider who
said she was gonna show up in the last
episode more or less and uh that didn't
happen so i'm not sure
you know where the the signals got
crossed on that but i do expect to see
her
does it kind of changes up things a
little bit i mean one of the theories on
her was that she might be um ed's you
know
doing ed's business since you know
robert forrester couldn't come back if
she would have been vacuum uh cleaner uh
that didn't happen obviously
um other ones was that she might be
kim's mother which uh it doesn't really
the timelines didn't really seem too
on the no they didn't seem right to me
but it's possible
uh the one that i thought was fun was
that maybe she is
jeff's mother you know i mean like jimmy
starts this uh thing in the gene
timeline with jeff and then
you know she becomes like the the hidden
boss that's behind jeff that that he
wasn't anticipating but
it's pretty hard to say you know
that she's not a lawyer you know she
could be a it was judge pompadumian was
a it was a question uh she could come
back in that one but it's like do we
really want to see
saul goodman in the courtroom
i don't know it depends if it's for a
good reason you know what i mean
it's kind of funny it feels a little bit
like
star wars has trained us anytime there's
a new character it's like okay who are
they related to whose mother or brother
sister or brother are they
part of me thinks that this is probably
going to be
a new character just a new character
just somebody that plays some important
role
that um maybe we don't even have at
least without looking at behind the
scenes stuff if you just look at what's
been presented on the show so far we
might just not have the information
needed to speculate on who that really
is
yeah so this is this one uh this
question from seth buehner kemper again
uh
30 thank you that's very generous um
i didn't get to this before we just
answered the the exact same question a
little bit ago um
i can't think of anything else to add to
it uh i i i do you know the second
question you have here
i do think that ending on a high note is
always a good thing to do
but you know at the same time if if if
the way if the if the the tv landscape
and the you know the ip
and what gets made and what gets
produced you know if it just happens to
play out that way that that there has to
be another show i mean this is one of
those universes that um
i wouldn't be upset about you know like
i don't know i mean the walking dead
you know i sort of stopped lost interest
in that a long time ago and it and it
surprises me that they continue to have
new shows all the time but i mean that
says something about how people
consume things you know what i mean like
if that show
you know it was huge whenever it was
when it was at its height if it you know
if it can still
bring in viewers by just spinning off
pieces of it then you know that that's
probably inevitable for for a universe
like this i don't know
i do think not on the topic of spin-offs
but just what i would look forward to
next i do think it's a fairly recent
phenomenon to have a showrunner whose
name people know who is there for the
entirety of the series like i think
walking dead has had a few different
show runners but there's i think
everybody in this chat right now knows
the name vince gilligan knows the name
peter gould and some people might know
the name tom schnauz and some of the
other writers and if i hear that one of
them is working on another show or
another movie or anything that's enough
to get me interested
so that's almost what has me more
excited than a potential spin-off is
just what else will these people create
next
yeah that's a big part of the the lord
of the rings show um i mean i'm not i'm
not super into
fantasy or
you know the tolkien verse necessarily
but knowing that jennifer
hutchinson is one of the main writers
definitely
makes me interested plus i mean i know
it's going to be a big production so
it's going to probably be pretty cool
either way but
yeah seeing her you know that's the the
next big thing that she did after
leaving better call saul that's exciting
because she was around through breaking
bad too so you know i mean she she
basically
shaped bcs a lot in the early seasons
raven scene thank you for the 10
canadian i think saul and kim get a bad
rap
this universe is pointing out the
unwillable hell of empire that meaning
or virtue can come through genuine
caring which saul does saul is just
coping
yeah i i mean i i think i can understand
where this sentiment comes from
and but i don't think you can i don't
think you can
say that it doesn't it i mean especially
after this episode
the choices they make matter
you know there's that they deal with the
consequences of their decisions and so
yeah they're it's it's complicated
and you know there there there is some
of what you're saying there but i would
say that it's more uh it's more complex
i mean i think especially after this
episode and and what we saw with
gus and mike that you know they're
they're saying hey look this is about
con this is about choices it's not just
about you know the way that
one one particular thing
you know people are reacting they react
in different ways and you know whenever
they make choices or they make decisions
they have to deal with what comes after
that
yeah this is not a value judgment on
either show but i think in some ways
this show is more complex than breaking
bad um
breaking bad was
all about one man's pride and then
talking about empire there i mean he's
trying to build one right um
this show yeah is is far more complex
the ways that the characters interact
with the
uh consequences in their own lives is
there's almost a straight line to draw
between walt and the consequences in his
life in this show it's
i think it's very different way more
complex
ed's hands
and that is ed scissorhands in your
avatar there
4.99 thank you very much what are your
thoughts about gene giving himself up
returning to albuquerque kim resurfacing
to represent him with carol burnett as
the judge um
okay this is something that i do want to
ask my guests as well this is something
i've been thinking about for a while and
um
i do feel i i have been thinking about
this him returning as being
that you know like you know if the
question is is there any jimmy left
inside saul or gene you know
is is the way that they get to that
you know if there is a redemption
if he would turn himself in at the end
that would that would show that right
that would that would that would confirm
that so it makes a lot of sense to me
that he would turn himself in
but then there's this idea of the
what would happen next and when i think
about him turning himself in i think it
works the best if that's just it like we
see him walk into
do that and we don't know what comes
next
we don't know how that plays out like i
don't really i don't really envision a
long uh you know epilogue of him going
through court and finding out what his
ultimate fate is but what do you what do
you think gil
yeah yes it's it's you know i've talked
so many times about wanting to see some
form of redemption for for jimmy as gene
and i think giving himself up would
definitely be
a way for that to manifest it's just
it's so hard to predict because one
thing i'm you know one thing we're used
to on these shows is having
you know for lack of a better word a
villain you know we've had lalo out
there for so long even on breaking bad
once they killed gus shortly after that
they introduced this gang of white
supremacist nazis
and i you know we have jeff hanging out
there and i think jeff is such an
unknown
is it just jeff who is this guy is he
just some guy
or is there some more powerful force
there and if that takes the focus we
might be asking more
how is jimmy going to get out of this
what's it going to cost him
you know and is he going to survive
there might be bigger questions i guess
than than him turning himself in
so
yeah i guess i'd like to see some form
of redemption that might mean giving
himself up but things also might get
really complicated where i don't even
know if that's necessarily going to be a
choice
yeah but i mean like structurally if he
was going to do that would you would you
think that they would have would set
that up in a way that we would get to
see the full conclusion
or do you think it makes more sense to
let the fans kind of put together what
they think would happen to jimmy in that
situation
yeah i feel like
i'm tempted to agree that they'd
probably say he's giving himself up and
find some
nice
place to kind of leave him on that
journey and leave it a little bit of a
question mark kind of similar to jesse
you know he you know he gets away
but you don't exactly know what happens
next you know until el camino
um
so
i think that's what my gut says we'd see
it's hard to picture some kind of
procedural courtroom we watch him go
through the process and everything it's
hard to see it being dramatically
compelling just to hear a courtroom say
back to him you know here's all the
things you did and here's your
punishment you know
yeah that's kind of what i think about
too what about you jim
that said some of these courtroom scenes
have been some of the most controversial
in the show right like that scene with
chuck
uh
to cannery yeah chicanery yeah fantastic
scene
but i agree with you i don't think um
it would feel very satisfying to watch
that process i think it feels more
satisfying just to know
that he's willing to do it and that he
has done it um
yeah because
with that feeling
because at the core that's what i want
is that i want i want to know that you
know
if he if he goes through this
if he
you know he's out there living as a
shell of a human being
in this in this lifestyle that he has
through breaking bad and and you know it
it just gets it just gets worse and then
he's he's stuck in in uh
you know omaha and you know the old old
question about omaha and the way that
you used to think or at least i used to
think about it was is like man this is
such a this is such a
an awful fate for this colorful guy that
was so
you know so dynamic in his time in
breaking bad and you know that's totally
kind of turned on its head too now that
he he was actually miserable and he was
he was just trying to deal with
you know the that that reality
but he was pining for those times you
know the opening of gene in the first
episode is him watching those old tapes
well that's what you thought i mean you
know it could it could be up to debate
now right true yeah
yeah
back on his bad choices and saying this
is how i got here you know yeah
and before i mean it was it was cut and
dry you know whenever i remember you
know we talked about this a little bit
before gail about how it just what a
mystery the whole thing with gene like
right now it's hard to almost remember
because
gene is just gene they did that for five
seasons they opened with it but the
first couple you were just sort of like
what is going on here
you know
and now they're recontextualizing that
at the at this late stage in the game
and that like well maybe we were
actually wrong about what we thought was
going on there you know yeah the gene um
scenes they really didn't have any
story until
when did we see the we saw jeff for the
first time in season four right that's
when he had the taxi driver yeah up
until then it was kind of like
gene's really sad
you know gene used to be saul goodman
and i loved those scenes but they almost
felt more like setting the tone kind of
a little reminder of where things are
heading we didn't really get true
progression in the story and think until
kind of season three i guess when he
collapsed i think that's when that
happened and then four we find jeff
hmm
yeah um eight sorry i just saw a comment
that said my my uh
audio was bad was it
has that been a problem no it sounds
sounds good to me
okay h and it's this is probably from
like an hour ago
and i can tell you from from experience
from last night if your audio is bad it
won't be one comment
yeah a lot more than one
[Laughter]
eight hn ic8 thank you for the 4.99
masterful episode masterful season the
season is already borderline the
greatest in the breaking bad universe
and with four episodes left
they will achieve this for sure and i
like your enthusiasm there
8 h n i c 8. um
i i agree it's been a great season uh
the knocks that that people had on the
beginning i think they've um definitely
you know they definitely proved that
patience
you know the patience was worth it at
this point for me i mean maybe not for
everybody but i i think so i think it's
uh just a great
great time right now and um
man i can't wait to see where they go
next
it would be it'll be devastating if if
if they if they were to drop the ball at
this point but i just like it's really
hard to envision it isn't it i mean
that'd be the saddest live stream ever
just us i don't know
just yeah so uh
you know all the other the first 12
episodes pretty great
this last one it just didn't work for me
you know
god i hope we don't run into that
mark rayburn thank you for the five
euros i think carol burnett character is
the vacuum cleaner's wife who is still
working the business
i thought i started to warm up to this a
little bit more last week
but i mean now that who needs the vacuum
cleaner person
right kim was the one that would have
made the most sense for that and she
doesn't need it anymore she's she's just
taking the matters into her own hands
i can't see gene calling him again
after the last time
yeah no he i think he he
he passed the point of no return on that
do you see any do you see any chance of
that happening anybody
no i don't think so
yeah okay
um
lapse of apathy thank you for the five
was that the only one who found the jump
from turning into saul kind of
depressing
i thought you were going to say too fast
or something based on some of the
comments
and i was going to be like yep you are
you're the only one
and other hundreds of people that were
commenting that same thing
but no um
yeah i found it absolutely depressing
it's kind of soul-crushing
and i think that's why the quick cut
really really emphasized that made that
work
did you guys think that somehow
uh the the the turntable bed made that
any less depressing
more depressing if anything i think the
more opulence they could put into that
scene
the more depressing it is because it
just feels so
hollow
am i missing something with that i mean
like you know i i've i've been around
the block um
i don't i can't ever remember thinking
this would this would be so much better
if if this was spinning around
you know i mean like i can kind of
understand magic fingers the things in
the in the motel you know or the bed
shakes if you put a quarter in but like
the spinning around it doesn't really
make sense to me is how that you know
heightens the experience for for me it's
a question of rpms but
sure
a little bit of
centrifugal uh
force is that what it is or uh
a little add a little a little
a little danger you know you might be
thrown off if you're not if you're not
like
derek kravitz thank you for the 499 love
the level of detail and respect for
timeline in this show thinking
specifically of the old school clinton
era 100 bill gus pays for wine with i
did think i i noticed that too and i
thought that was a nice touch um
i can't think of anything else to tie
into this uh
that was cool in this episode but
that one did stand out to me the old uh
before they had the um
the big photo on there and the the sort
of uh
what's it called the um
the strip and the the way that you know
i mean those hundred dollar bills they
were like that for my entire life until
i think it was around 2000 or so they
started to switch those so
it was cool to see that
not that i carried around a lot of
hundred dollar bills before that but
i envy had seen them familiar with
hundred dollar bills
yeah i had seen them i mean but when you
know when i was younger i guess a
hundred dollar bill that was like you
would feel scared if you were walking
around with that much money sometimes
lax lifters thank you for the five
dollars i think i thought lyle would
have suffered a similar fate as howard
being at the wrong place at the wrong
time and being
too enthusiastic and
gus having mike do it oh okay
you got a little bit
thrown off on that second part of the
sentence
yeah i think that this is a joke
um
and it's funny yeah i mean if they a few
episodes ago if they were like you know
lyle has a wife and we meet her and we
start to get to know him a little bit i
would have started to worry about him
yeah
lyle i i mentioned this in last week's
stream like i i
lyles is one of those characters he's
just plugging away out there and you
know you kind of think man this is i
really like this character but you never
have a reason to talk about that and
then like the last episode you know i
was thinking that like i was so into the
lyle stuff and then
go online and apparently everybody loves
them just as much as i do
you know
about that to be a big surprise like oh
okay it's not just me this is this guy
is awesome
and then i found out it was dave
thomas's kid like that's that's really
crazy
bob and doug mckenzie
yeah huh he sctv yeah not not the the
wendy's one
okay well
disappointing
but yeah he he posted it on twitter he
posted this is my you know this is my
son i forget what lyle's first name is
in real life harrison maybe or something
like that and uh
yeah he was like
posting pra proud dad pics of
lyle and gus together
i don't know which one he was was he bob
or doug mckenzie i think he was doug
mckenzie
but i remember i had a a tape like it
was one of my cousins or uncles or
something that it's one of those things
you come across when you're a kid
and it's like you have not so many
things so you just like focus on it so
like i had a period where it wasn't even
like
you know
current anymore i just had this old tape
of
bob and doug mckenzie and i was super
into it because you know like i said i
didn't have that many other things to
listen to i used to do that with vhs
tapes i think i won bill and ted's bogus
journey probably about 150 times just
come home from school start watching
bill and ted every day
not because it was bad or good or
anything else it was just because that
was in the vcr
yeah
the people don't really get that like
how that was i don't think anymore you
know i mean it's like
you know
like
you you had like i remember like you
you'd have things like that where you
would you would know about stuff but you
would never actually see it and you
would just talk about knowing about it
you know what i mean like i heard this i
heard there's this movie
that you know that that does this and
now you can just literally if you hear
about it you can just watch it within
minutes i remember for me that was the
mario brothers movie i was like they
made a movie based on that game and then
i was like tracking it down i found like
the one specific library in my state
that had a copy of it and that was i was
so excited to watch it and then i
watched it
and then it didn't live up to the the to
the love you had for the idea that it
was just out there somewhere right you
know
the journey was all about the journey
jojo's asmr
smr
thank you for the a5
i know they expect us to put pieces
together but maybe we could see a short
montage of saul getting the statue
his new car and changed office
i don't really expect them to go back
they could um
i think that there could be
uh courtney who um
you know was on last weekend who will be
on the saturday stream this week she she
had the uh she mentioned it to me i
don't i don't know if it was her idea in
the first place but she mentioned to me
the ice uh
ice station zebra associates
could be run by the kettleman's and then
that that has something to do with how
how that
you know comes into his
his um
you know be on top of the building peter
gould said something about like you know
because they they had that they had the
saul goodman associate sign that they
showed up in the uh teaser
you know in the first episode and then
they showed them putting that on there
and um he was saying about how like that
was
to show how
that was the end of her vision
francesca's vision and of course
sometime in between the beginning of the
episode and the end of the episode
they you know he he decided to change it
all and um it didn't sound to me like
they were going to fill in those blanks
but
you know he did mention that
they're aware of you know of it so maybe
it's possible that we might see some
more of it
let's see here jacob cahill thank you
for the two is the flash forward
2005-2008 um we believe it's 2005
but we can't say for sure they could be
uh they could have made a mistake with
the license plate but that's the
evidence
jacob cahill thank you for the five
dollars when he references public fill
in the blank
it makes me think breaking bad era with
the badger mix-up reference
yeah like we we answered this already
earlier and you know that that's i can
see where you're coming from but if it
is 2005 like your last question referred
to then that wouldn't make sense
lapse of apathy thank you for the 10
also notice how there
is symbolism in the mug being a
juxtaposition of the second best lawyer
thermos
yeah i mean the the world's best lawyer
or world's greatest lawyer mug that's
something that existed in breaking bad
i thought it's kind of funny here that
you say well okay
he maybe he graduated that because kim's
no longer a lawyer that adds a little
bit of context to that but um
yeah that's not a new that that's not a
new thing for him he he had that i think
it's even in the opening credits isn't
it
i think it is yeah it is it is sad
though to to juxtapose the two of them
because that second best lawyer mug had
that sentimental value it came from kim
she tossed it in the trash after it got
shot
and uh now he's bought himself this
soulless
mug that sits on his desk
yeah it is absolutely sad that's true
okay there's another question here from
jacob thank you for the 10 again and
this is what we just talked about um
do we have anything else we can say
about that i i don't
would that be a good thing if
that is a reference to
badger do we want to see walt and jesse
right at that point or do we do is there
anything we can talk about there that
you guys have any
favorite pet theory of how they come
back
not really i mean i think for me uh this
reference is is almost more just the the
comedy of saul goodman just that of
course this is what he's gonna be
dealing with so frequently that he's
gonna say another case like this
but in terms of pet theories at this
point i am just waiting to see what they
come up with because like you've said so
many times
it's not going to be a fan service cameo
sounds like it might even be more than a
cameo somehow it has to serve the jimmy
mcgill character or serve a character on
this show and their story i can't wait
to see what that is i'm very excited to
find out
all right tony b two four two seven four
two four seven thank you for the 199.
kim's no lawyer
who does he tell francesca to call
that's an interesting question we've
touched on this several times in um
other streams but you know it there's no
more hhm
they did address that they're going to
downsize it's have a different name so
it could be them but i don't know who
who he has over there anymore that he
would talk to
it's two separate things he he gives her
a card and he tells friends francesca to
tell him jimmy sent you
and then he also
asked her if she'll be there when this
other call comes in at a predisposed
time on his birthday
so yeah i never really had a great idea
and as they killed off
howard
it got harder to guess who that card
might be
and i think it you know i i don't think
that they probably knew whenever they
had that scene happen you know i mean i
think they just said we'll have him do
this thing and then we'll figure it out
later
that seems to be their process as far as
writing but you know
you guys have any other thoughts on that
there's a cliff
could be right you basically just name
any lawyers that we know are still
like yeah jimmy though
yeah
cliff might not i mean
cliff i've got you know let's just say
real quick that cliff that that was
he really killed that performance too um
in that he like he i think ed begley jr
really elevated that scene with cheryl
because
he was us you know he's just like man i
feel so awful about this whole thing you
know i mean like he saw both sides of it
he doesn't want to tell her he doesn't
want to like hurt her anymore
but he's totally had the wolf pulled
over his eyes because of what jim and
kim you know kimmy kim and jimmy did
like man he he really pulled that off i
thought like i mean of course he's a
good actor but
it's nice to have that guy in your back
pocket when you need that you know that
seam to work
rhubarb pie thank you for the 4.99
considering her behavior all season was
kim's breakup and jimmy now more
insidious which she had left anyways if
howard lived no i don't think she would
i think that they made that pretty
explicit that um
she wants to be in the relationship
she loves jimmy that that's not the
question the question is if if
if they're together they're poisoned
and if they are then you know she can't
really live with that because she knows
that that you know people around them
will get hurt as a result
do you have you know
yeah she already knew this is is the
thing like
that's the thing that's so tragic about
howard's death it didn't need to happen
and i think you're right they would have
broken up sooner um and kim lays out the
the the problem here right like if she
had told
jimmy about lalo being alive he would
have gone off and done his jimmy thing
and he would have
called off the operation on howard uh
which would have cut off her fun which
is like the thing that she actually
cared about and she would have broken up
with him so like
there's there's a scenario where this
works out and howard doesn't die
and that is not the one that she chose
to go down and she did it for her own
selfish reasons
though i do think that
something was inevitable if they got
past howard and
he was just bruised and nothing more
then i think they would have
looked for an even bigger scam to pull
because they want to have even more fun
uh you know they're looking for a bigger
hit so i think at some point something
like this would have happened and who
knows maybe by then they're too deep
into it and whatever moral fibers are
left in kim are burned out by that point
um
but but yeah i think if howard lived and
this all worked out they wouldn't have
broken up but there's a good chance
something like this would have happened
anyway
eventually yeah when you're when you're
talking about there i thought about that
i really like how they set that up
because jimmy he goes into the other
room and he starts saying you know it
wasn't your fault it wasn't my fault it
was lalo you know
and um i like that choice there where
she just she doesn't even she doesn't
even really engage with that she just
she just goes to telling him that hey
you know what i lied i i knew he was
still alive and i chose to ignore it and
i chose to keep that from you because i
wanted to keep this thing going
so yeah that is
you know like i said it's sort of a sort
of a shift of responsibility there you
know like yeah it is lalo's fault
ultimately but
i'm gonna put that on me because of the
choices that i made and and there's
you know part of that makes sense you
know right
bill spruce thank you for the three
howard is the perfect shakespearean
tragic feature uh
figure
can't say that i disagree with that
very tragic
2k is easy
thank you for the 4.99 with kim story
being done lalo nacho and howard being
done aside from gene's timeline what can
they really do with four episodes left
i think we're gonna see two breaking bad
and two gene
maybe three gene one breaking bad maybe
they're all gonna be mixed together
but i think that
kim's story is not
necessarily done
um i mean we've kind of touched on this
so you
anything new come to mind that that you
want to add at this point
either one of you
no
particular all right yeah so i i think
you know we
i i just i i'm i'm thinking about this
because we are doing a stream about that
on saturday and i'll do a preview video
before that and i'm kind of in a play at
least last night whenever i was going
you know going to sleep i i was kind of
at a place like
man i i kind of just
want to see what they have in store you
know i mean like i i feel like it's
almost beyond um being able to guess
based on the fact that the way that they
reset everything after this last episode
rohin gupta thank you for 200
something that i can't really
is nihilism most fundamental motivation
of jimmy and kim um
not in my mind um
like i said i think jimmy is
uh
that he wants to be loved
that he wants to be respected
uh a lot of that stems from his
inability to get that from chuck
kim i think up until this episode it was
about justice
um you know
doing you know through her pro bono work
i mean
that she's sincere in that i i've seen
people say like
oh well that thing with cliff proved
that she never cared about the pro bono
work that it doesn't it doesn't
in my mind and maybe you guys have a
different take on it but
in my mind she's choosing the scam over
that but it doesn't mean that that
doesn't matter i mean she can be two
things you know right and that was in
the heat of the scam like it was about
to go down so the excitement level
um i think in that moment she
prioritized the scam over that but i
don't think that necessarily says
and i i definitely don't think it says
that the pro bono stuff is just you know
a fake thing i think it's legitimate
yeah i think more conflicted character
in a lot of ways than jimmy is um
i think she she does have the streak
where she just wants to have fun and
scam
and she wants that to be her life but
she also does believe in justice and
believe in helping people
and that's a motivator too and those
things come into conflict pretty often
um
and ultimately that's it's what does the
relationship in
yeah i mean you could say that that that
saul
you know that there's some nihilism
going on there um
but not for the core characters i don't
think
this one says uh thank you dottie x for
the 199. heard tom s said francesca
phone call don't happen and i did see
that tweet but i don't know that he was
being sincere
um
he was saying it to alan steppenwall if
i recall correctly and
i don't know i i i didn't take it as
like okay you can just take this comment
at face value it sounded like he was
there was some kind of uh
it was a little bit of banter
do you guys have either one of you guys
know what i'm talking about here
i didn't see the tweet but knowing tom
like just knowing the way he tweets
i i assume that he was joking yeah alan
steppenwall someone asked someone asked
ellen steppenwall i hope i'm not getting
that mixed up because it's been about a
week or so since i saw it and um
you know hey what about that call and
and
steppenwall said uh well of course
they wouldn't have you know they have to
touch on that
they wouldn't have brought it up if they
weren't gonna to you know
revisit it at some point
and thomas sniles just answered no
to him
like you know just awesome like
completely just you know
what are you talking about that's
definitely not something we're gonna do
so it didn't like it said it seemed more
like a joke than anything
also come on they brought up the the
chile stuff with gus and they haven't
touched on it since so
they'll leave some loose ends it's not
they will yeah love them
and this one brings up chile right
here uh dub jay thank you for the five
and breaking bad a lot of you said
during gus flashback he spared his life
because he knew about his true past in
chile
i think it would be pop think it'd
possibly be elaborated on still um we
answered this earlier dub um
i'm not sure if you were around but
we we don't think so
that's the the consensus
it's possible
but it's kind of hard to see how that
would serve the bigger story of what's
going on
and uh that little bit of mystery like
you know jim just mentioned is
it's nice to preserve some of that
it's nice to have some questions left in
your head after the story wraps up
because then you keep thinking about it
okay i'm scrolling here
uh you know i we didn't really talk
about what your what how much time you
guys had so if you if you need to um
yeah i might bounce in a few minutes
partially because as people saw in the
stream last night and after another full
day of traveling today i'm sort of
starting to run on fumes
but uh but i'll give it a few more
minutes
yeah i mean i'm going to stay till the
end no matter what and you're welcome
too if you want but you know if you have
to get somewhere i understand
what are you looking like jim
uh i have a podcast to edit tonight uh
but
i can do it a little bit longer yeah
all right so yeah just let me know
because i'm gonna i'm just sort of
scrolling through the the comments in my
it takes up half of my attention so
if you need to just
let me know and then we'll we'll say
we'll do our goodbyes
um
seth
buenan camper that's an eight dollar you
know that doesn't have a question i'm
just looking to see if there was
something that followed that up but
thank you again for that
um
brxh thank you for the 199.
what will the intros look like for
episodes 11 to 13.
you know i never saw a good um
i never saw a good theory about that uh
you guys understand this i'm sure like
you know there was
10 episodes in every season they
degraded they used the same one every
time they degraded season over season
because it's a vhs tape you know that's
being watched over and over again
so where did they go
i thought they could um
maybe do better call saw
commercials i thought maybe that might
be fun you know what i mean like to do
like a quick one
that was the title credits do you guys
have any ideas how they could replace
the old ones with something new
just all static like the tape's not even
running anymore or if the if the tapes
have been degrading and now we've time
skipped have they introduced dvds at
this point it's actually quality to
improve
we can get a weird melding it's like a
breaking bad slash better call saul
starting with the two songs are like
mixed together
i'll find out
yeah
uh seth beuninkemper thank you for the
five i felt like howard's wife was not a
believable character
excuse me uh there are not many onsol
any others come to mind
yeah i don't know you you didn't really
explain why you didn't think she was
believable so it's a little bit hard to
say i i you know i mentioned earlier i
thought they did a great job of flushing
her out and making her feel like
you know i knew who she was
so i didn't share your opinion on that
who's the pill guy
can't remember his name
he's the best guys
yeah the guy who was selling the pills
in earlier scenes oh uh price daniel
yeah
he's about as close as like an
unrealistic character i can think of in
this show but
i it didn't bother me certainly it was
entertaining to watch
yeah he's a little bit cartoony like
oblivious to a point where
i could see it it's it's stretching it a
little bit but um but he was such a such
a delightful character i really didn't
mind it right
there was the thing going in and this it
actually makes me think of another thing
but there was a thing on imdb that said
he was coming back and i i thought it
was someone trolling because i was just
like how would they fit him into the
story
and that did turn out to be the case but
we're watching this really serious
episode with all these big answers and
endings and i'm still thinking in the
back of my mind
that price might show up at any second
and that really you know that says all i
need to know about that character is
yeah like i agree with you guys he is a
little bit
cartoony but
he he he owned my mind in the last
episode just thinking that he might come
back
and that's saying something you know and
you know i just wanted to say because i
didn't bring it up in my in my video and
i made it but
i'm watching the opening credits you
know i'm on the edge of my seat waiting
for this episode to come for the first
time you know watching on tv and i saw
papa vargas name in the credits and man
that was the thing like whoa
why is he in this you know
they're not going to kill him after all
that are they like that would be insane
so yeah i thought that was that was that
really kind of set the tone because i
was like
where the hell are they going to bring
him back in you know like i just you
know the actor's name and i was just
like oh my god and now i'm worried that
they're going to be going after him in
this episode i don't know pete do you
remember on one of these live streams
when people were asking about nacho's
father and i said he might come back
just so we can see mike attempt to give
him some closure
yeah i do remember remember that okay
cool
yeah you were on you're on there and and
um you know like i i remember when we
talked about at the time i i didn't
think it was necessary but i thought it
would be good
and it's crazy that they actually
you know they turned it into something
much bigger than that yeah you know
because mike kind of gets it thrown in a
space that you know hey
you're not like me you know like
he did that he did the honorable thing
and and it doesn't change the fact that
it was it was right but his motivation
and and then his idea of justice you
know
having that come back you know it's
pretty substantial part like he
papa varga you know
beyond being the victim of losing the
sun he
you know that's a pretty big
contribution to the breaking bad
universe when you think about it
karl west thank you for the 1 pound 79
what was the happy ever after teaser
what was the happy ever after teaser
addressed
um
[Music]
that happy ending one is that with your
i'm not it was one of those teasers
where it was like uh a happy ending
after all this or something like yeah i
made a video about that one that's why
i'm wondering if happy ever after is the
same or not i was just gonna say you
could go and and look i i did i did a
video because what stood out to me about
that particular teaser was is like what
does a happy ending even look like for
these two anymore after howard died you
know like i want a happy ending for them
but i no longer know what that
actually is because you know we were all
in the in the in the moment of shock
after howard died as as a result of
their plan you know
if you guys want to chime in on that you
feel free i mean i i don't know uh
if that's
if there's anything else to say
yeah it gets you thinking i mean like
like you want a great show to do it gets
you to think about
people keep asking questions like do
they deserve a happy ending or what do
they deserve
and it's it's a concept that you think
about in real life but at the same time
you kind of recognize it's there's no
force in the universe or i guess i can't
say that definitively but at least i
believe there's no
supernatural force in the universe that
ensures people get exactly what they
deserve so there's the question of
i guess what do they need to do so they
can be at peace and be happy you know do
they need to take a certain amount of
punishment do they need to do a certain
amount of good in the world to balance
the scales like mike kind of accused gus
of doing so i think about it on two
levels one is what's going to happen in
this story what can i actually envision
but it does take you back down an
interesting path of
you know applying it to the real world
just
it gets you to think about those things
yeah i thought that was what the
brilliance of putting lalo and howard
next to each other in the grave was you
know it's like
on some levels howard did everything
right you know he
he went down he can't he brought himself
back up
and you know it just it just shows you
that the universe is in fact not fair
you know i did one detail in that howard
scene that every time i talk about it i
mean to bring it up and i always forget
to
which is that if he had left you know a
minute earlier he would have been fine
and i think the last thing he says is
basically i'm going to dedicate the rest
of my life to
making sure everyone everyone knows what
frauds you are and it's sort of like the
moment he dipped his toe into that
revenge like i'm gonna go down this path
of destroying you two lalo shows up so
he didn't deserve it
but but it almost he kind of crossed
that line a little bit
yeah he's no angel but um he's
definitely he definitely didn't deserve
what happened either
i like that i like that uh twist there
about thinking you know especially after
the last episode i hadn't i hadn't
really considered that
because you kind of you know he kind of
feels justified in that and you kind of
feel like yeah i kind of hope you do get
that you know i hope you i hope you do
uh you expose them as frauds
but it is a change and it is an actual
change in the character
danielle and fonte thank you for the
4.99 what does kim leaving jimmy and
going away mean for gus and mike is
there any reason for gus to care about
kim and jimmy now lalo is dead
yeah there was a lot of people that had
brought this up going in
and
i even started to consider that maybe
gus
you know would would want to you know
that they that he would look at them as
knowing too much or whatever
i think that i think by the fact that
they added that line of him saying to
mike what about the lawyers
i felt like that was um
you know that was their saying like hey
gus doesn't care about this
yeah yeah i saw some people asking you
know kim
leaving law
would be a big red flag that might make
people suspicious
and uh mike or gus wouldn't be too happy
about that but i think the main thing
they wanted was for them to act natural
up until
howard's death becomes public and at
this point there's every reason for
people to think people who are close to
howard would be rattled and nobody would
look at her quitting and say wait a
minute could she have had something to
do with this you know so i think they're
safe at least from that standpoint
yeah it might even be more suspicious if
they show up missing
right
negan the cliffhanger thank you for 4.99
uh it's about stds
uh
how does this affect the storyline going
forward well
it's between him and his uh
sex workers i guess huh
i was gonna say the next question is the
one i'm gonna go out on but i i gotta
wait for the next one
yeah
um
when i was scrolling there i lost it too
i had the next one here we go
radio chaos thank you for the canadian
five they could do tuko's struggle as a
drive-through cashier before he joins
the cartel how about this one gail is
this the one you're going to go out on
or uh i guess i guess we'll have to make
it this one but but i will say that if
if they do a spin-off about tuco
as a drive-through cashier that would
tell me that peter gould vince gilligan
are probably not involved this was amc
saying we got it we gotta get a spin off
and i feel like they're gonna they're
gonna follow the money and right now
everybody wants to see more lyle so i've
seen people bandy about you know better
dial so that's a much more likely
spin-off than this one
yeah gordon smith said on the on the
insider podcast that they actually
do they actually did write songs and
scenes for a lile
a fictitious lyle spinoff like they they
actually throw the idea around
and uh i forget what they said they they
called it but
it's a real thing it starts as a joke
but then they say wait a minute we may
have something here
i think they could do that i mean i
think they could actually make a lial uh
spin-off work
he's gonna i mean he's got a world of
pain coming to him when he finds out
that his his hero is is
king
i might accuse you of going uh going on
the click bait route if tomorrow i see a
video from you that's
how the while spin-off could actually
work
yeah
all right i think i'm gonna sign off
here uh if you guys don't mind i'm gonna
bounce but uh this was a lot of fun
i think um hopefully for some of these
last few i'll be able to stick around
and we can we can go you know three
hours or i i assume as we get closer to
the finale there's going to be even more
and more to talk about
um so so i'm excited for that but thank
you as always pete for having me on and
jim great talking with you yeah you too
yeah and i'll you know check out his
channel i'll have links in the
description uh for that and his podcast
so always good to have you on um
we'll we'll be back again next week and
like i said i'm gonna be doing saturday
so if you want to or if you're around
you can let me know and we can just
throw everybody on there if need be so
all right awesome i'll let you know talk
to you soon
all right
see ya see ya uh i might also head out
it looks like all of your super chats
from here on out are lyle based uh
and if anybody's heard my podcast from
last week
boy you're you're lyle stuff
i don't know i did a particularly harsh
rant against lyle uh mostly because he
was singing the los polos theme song uh
yeah episode oh that's right i listened
to that now i remember that uh you
you're not prolial
very anti-lyle but it only happened it
was in the moment man i i did not
pre-plan any of that i was just like you
know what lyle sucks and here's why uh i
laid it all out so
i don't know that i have a lot to
comment on uh positively with lyle
yeah hey i i get it um you know it's i
just watched the show the bear i don't
know if you if you watched that oh not
yet no
yeah it's pretty cool but it it kind of
it
that that kind of i was kind of thinking
of a lyle spinoff whenever i was
watching that because
it does this great thing where you know
it focuses in on the job that they do
and it's like this you know
weird group of people that are brought
together like every single job that
everybody does like that in in the
entire world you know what i mean
so it really scrub the grill
you know not never for quite as long as
what lyle did but i mean it is an
integral part of some of what they're
doing there so yeah it and i do
recommend it if you if you check it out
it's a it's a half an hour fx one is
kind of like in that um
vein of mr in between or something like
that you know what i mean it's like a 30
minute drama but uh
i think there was eight episodes so
you're only looking at like maybe four
and a half
five hours because couple of them are
extended but
it's pretty cool it's a pretty cool
little show
yeah it's fun i've been meaning to get
to
yeah so um thanks for coming on it's
great to see you uh you know as always
you can come back whenever you want um
crazy that we only got a few more of
these left
so man
and uh you know i've been listening to
your for all mankind stuff because i've
been super sucked into that and nobody
really seems to care about it i know
it's a great show though great show
it really is the third season has been
so much fun i was gonna send you guys an
email saying that if you wanted to get
together i i don't think i can really do
a thing on here because it's just it
wouldn't get that many views but
yeah and that's a lot of words anymore i
know i didn't put a ton of work into
your videos yeah if you want to come on
the podcast and just chat sometime about
it
absolutely yeah
yeah i'll hit you up on that so uh
yeah so you want to plug anything or
whatever before you go just give these
guys your
uh yeah if you're looking for another uh
better call saw podcast to listen to
better casts all i do with my co-host
aaron over on baldmove.com or you know
bettercast all in any favorite uh
podcast app you have
that's where we're at
yep i highly recommend it i've been
listening to their podcasts for years
and uh we talk tv all the time so
check it out for sure
you can find it in the description
cool thank you for having me on this is
a lot of fun
all right see ya have a good one
all right now i'm gonna get through the
rest of these super chats and i'll stay
as long as it takes i'll meet his army
thank you for the 449 euro
well we see other big characters again
eladio hector tuko chuck howard
flashback even characters that we
haven't seen like emilio declan cooby
etc uh there's a lot of people that you
mentioned there i felt like eladio
hector um i felt like that was
kind of their end
for better call saul i don't really see
a good reason to bring them back um
tuko we kind of skipped over when he got
out of jail so i think that's less
likely than it was before
chuck howard flashback um
i would like i would always i always
like some chuck but um
yeah i i you know it's it's 50 50 i
would say i i feel like howard is
not as i feel like if i had to choose
between the chuck and the howard i'd
pick chuck
howard's still fresh in our memory chuck
is he's such a big part of shaping jimmy
into the person that he is
i think that that would be you know
fantastic but i've also heard them say
like you know that they don't want to
use that too much you know
i mean when you have michael mckean
available and you can do that
there's probably you know
that there's probably an impulse to like
let's do that every season or every
chance we can get and they you know they
have to kind of hold off on that
emilio declan cooby i mean kuby was
always always made sense because
you know he he him and heal are together
and they're a pretty big part of what's
going on
he made sense in the bcs timeline um
but they couldn't make that work in
season five they used
mr x instead because uh bill burr wasn't
available
i don't really care about declan or
emilio unless it's uh you know unless
it's about
tying the others in you know
like um
we'll see though we'll see
john lackowski thank you for the five is
there any chance that kim becomes a
reinvented version of herself and is
actually the character that she's
currently playing in cooper's bar um i
only watched the first episode of that
but i didn't see
any real connection there
and so no i i i that wouldn't be my
guess i don't think that's the way that
they're going but um
i think that she will reinvent herself
if she's not going to be a lawyer and
you know she probably has
a decent amount of savings from from her
time working with mesa verde but she's
going to have to do something
and um
she doesn't have the the the the re you
know getting
getting re-uh
placed like
you know gene did you like to become a
whole new person like that she's gonna
have to do you know build something of
her own
seth bernard
berner kemper sorry i mess it up every
time 35 that is very generous thank you
very much uh i stay i station zebra
the diamonds
the call in season four flash forward
francesca are these needed to be
addressed
i would say ice station zebra not
necessarily um
they laid the the
they laid the groundwork of why he would
name it that whether kim's involved or
not you know that was always the big
question about that is can is it called
that because kim's involved with that um
i feel like that's less likely now and i
still feel like it makes sense that he
would name that because you know he had
this check that was made out to ice
station zebra
hanging on the mirror of their their
room for for a couple of seasons there
so it's not like something that he would
forget
yeah i think the diamonds it would be
nice to figure out where he gets those
but
maybe it just kind of makes sense in
that you know he's got this opulent
lifestyle that he we didn't know about
before
in the mcmansion so um i think it would
be cool i i feel like those will
probably play a part in the end they
wouldn't have introduced them if they
you know they weren't planning on doing
something with that
when i made my uh teaser breakdown about
that that call where he tells him to you
know tell someone on the other line to
leave him alone that they're not friends
i thought maybe he might be paying off
jeff and that might come into it there
we talked about the the call with
francesca earlier um
you know i i do believe that they will
that will
we'll find out what's up with that
i don't i mean
if any of it they don't need to if it
doesn't serve the story i don't think
they should suffer i don't think they
should you know take away from from
what's working just because they want to
stick something in there but
um it's nice when they can they can
they can tie off all those loose ends
hence shurler thank you for the two
dollars do we have closure on the fish
tank um
i i don't think so i i i do kind of
wonder
if they move out where it went
it's not shown up in the um
the mansion as far as i know we don't
see it as office
ever
uh you know maybe we'll see something
else with that
in the future
i saw that they were cleaning the blood
spatter off of that um
in the last episode so
hopefully the the fish isn't too
traumatized from that
backs thank you for the five it's been
rumored that they lost saul's watch in
breaking bad and replaced it
what do you think of them now giving
jimmy and lalo the same watch oh
man i don't even know anything about
what you're talking about here
um
they lost saul so you're saying like the
production company lost saul's white or
salt
uh watch
um
this isn't the story i ever heard of and
i didn't realize that jimmy and lalo had
the same one either
so i'm sorry
uh i don't i i don't have anything
that i can say about that
made in brooklyn 1975 thank you for the
10
am i wrong for thinking that neither kim
nor jimmy ever express any remorse for
the role they played in howard's death
or the destruction of his reputation
even after his death yeah i would say
you're wrong
i'd say that kim breaking up with jimmy
expresses that
pretty explicitly
and the way that she said that
we hurt people around us and people
bad things happen
because we come together and because i
believe that and i feel bad about
everything that happened
i need to leave i need to end this
relationship i mean that was my take on
it
and uh you know it makes sense to me so
i don't i don't really
i don't know what you mean by um
express beyond like saying it out loud
there i feel like this pretty explicit
they haven't gotten trouble for it yet
and that's what that would come in if he
ends up turning himself in at the end um
wash up 84 thank you for the five i
don't get mike and gus's relationship
from bcs to bb now and bcs mike has
messed up stuff for gus
and he also doesn't seem to like us
well i don't think they're friends and i
don't think they ever
were friends in breaking bad either
and i and i do sort of
see where you're coming from tyrus was
and you know in this last season
especially tyrus was kind of at the top
of the food chain
and mike was clearly clearly under him
where in breaking bad that seems to be
how you know switched i guess they could
explain that to us i don't but i i just
feel like
we also know mike is a really uh
valuable guy and and he's the kind of
guy that would work his way up so i
don't think they need to
um and i just don't think you know i
don't think he has respect for gus
that's i think that's pretty clear you
know like he
he you know he has his reasons for
working with him because he knows he's
good at it and he and it's the it's the
you know it's the hand that he's been
dealt he's playing the hand that he's
been dealt but
i don't think he'll he'll ever have any
uh you know he'll ever feel
good about what gus does or that he's a
part of it for that matter
blue stomach
thank you for the two i'm disappointed
wanted to see how saul got the caddy um
that's fair uh
it's not a it's not a
you know it's not something that is
bothering me i i mean to me it seems
like this says
this gave us a little bit more
information like you know there was a
time when people thought that this might
be a gift from the cartel or something
like that i mean
now we know that he probably just bought
it off the lot and it's just part of
everything else that he has going on
there and this crazy lifestyle he has
you know like and when you saw that from
the break from things in the the
perspective of breaking bad
you didn't really know if
jimmy or saul you know that was was
actually
thriving you know he he was really kind
of
you know insistent that they continue to
cook meth and and keep that going so
like you know there was always the
possibility that
he wasn't really doing that well now we
know he's actually
kind of loaded
so he's doing it for fun and you know
for the coping mechanism
space king two dollars let's get gila
gill of gold
gill a gould
gillico
or gil a goat trending
go for it man let's do it um
let's see here
ab thank you for the 4.99 what's up with
the new teaser a robbery a commercial
shoot a robbery disguised as a
commercial shoot don't know what to
expect from gene
yeah i was talking to kiwi about this
yesterday like after the episode we're
talking about the episode and then he
was he asked me and i only watched it
the one time you know like i watched it
at the end of the episode then i went
straight into
you know
getting ready to make my recap so
my initial take without looking at it
very closely was that
it was probably
gene you know he was doing something at
the mall to create a commotion you know
like he was
it sounded like he was talking over the
pa as far as i could tell
and that he was like telling people to
you know take stuff like you know
trying to just come just trying to get
some something
chaotic to pop off and uh
you know obviously that would be to his
advantage but that's as far as i could
go with it i mean they didn't really
there's not really much else so those
teasers are really good in that way that
they're just you know
it hints that there's chaos to come but
we're not really sure how that's going
to play out or even when you know
trustee thank you for the five kim
swearing in could be reflection to
howard or to
a new or re-swearing into florida or new
mexico bar
yeah i know that there is a thing out
there
[Music]
there's a photo
and you know that's led a lot of people
to believe that there is
florida in her future
um
this is something i never really looked
into it i got it spoiled for me a couple
of times and i never really knew what
the the providence of it was or if it
was reliable
so i just don't really
talk about it or try to think about it
because i you know i want to see it
organically in the show but um
yeah that one teaser i thought the same
thing that you know she's
she could go to a different state and
you know become a lawyer
but now i mean you know she she would
have to there would have to be something
in her story that changes because right
now she feels like she shouldn't be able
to
practice law
you know like it's not
it's something that she's chosen you
know that she doesn't she doesn't think
it's it's the right thing for her so
something would have to happen to make
her change her mind
i'm not seeing any more here but there
has to be because i see some at the top
so
i apologize for the time and the
scrolling
all right here we go
it's his hands again thank you for the
499
gene ask him to turn him in
he pleads guilty she gets the 5 million
to start her pro bono practice and that
would explain her getting sworn in again
i mean yeah
uh
you know there's a there's definitely
some dots to connect to make that
possible i see where you're coming from
and how that could make sense
um
but there's also this you know there's
this there's this thing where you know
he's being pressured by jeff so
if he's been in
omaha for a while then we have to
imagine that he's not in touch with her
for a while too so
um we'll see
all right
claudette garrity thank you for the 919
1999 where does kim go
great question
as that last uh a couple of questions
ago there there is a
idea that she may end up in florida a
lot of people for you know ever since
jean showed up in omaha have been saying
that she'd go back to omaha but
i never really liked that idea because
she ran away from there as a choice and
there was nothing really for her to go
back for that we know of i mean
obviously
i i don't know it just it just never
seemed like
the character would go back to where she
came from that she left on purpose you
know i mean like
there's no it doesn't really seem to be
any nostalgia or or connections there
that that she's missing out on on not
being there
so i think the answer i think the
correct answer to this question based on
what we know is that she could go
anywhere
and it'll be exciting to see what where
she decides to go and how that you know
how it is i i did think earlier when we
were talking about the phone call and
the idea of only once a year you know
that i i do think that she'll
she'll want to keep that a secret
from jimmy because you know he
you can't really imagine that
he
he will uh
he would he would be able to can control
himself
and you know turn that off
or go to the extreme of being this much
of a soul
if there was possibility that he could
get back together
[Music]
all right
mir
camo thank you for the five usually the
crew makes a shirt paying tribute to the
character leaving dying
and they guest on the podcast not this
time with kim
yeah i did notice that i was expecting
to hear
rey and then
it was interesting because they didn't
have ann circus on there either
and they mentioned that towards the end
of the insider podcast that she wasn't
available because of kovid and so that
might be something to think about why
they didn't do it that way
but like yeah i i never felt like this
this i thought this was a great ending
for the relationship but not the
character i thought that that you know i
thought that it was a pretty perfect uh
way to to pop her out of the the
immediate story and then transition into
soul
but i mean come on it was
it didn't feel like the last time we
would ever see her
and you know part of that is is cope
you know like i want more but
i think i think it's legitimate you know
there's there's more to to see and and
just to play devil's advocate on what
you're saying the other two characters
you're talking about did die and she she
didn't so you know that could be a
a different um explanation for that
dan thank you for the 499. is there a
chance kim still dies or shows up in
present time when saul is hiding
definitely that she shows up i think
that that is baked in and you know
that's almost like they almost have if
she doesn't show up in the in the gene
timeline then uh you know then they have
to explain why that didn't happen almost
because it's just so
it's just so essential to the character
you know like
he could turn himself in because he
knows that she's never coming back like
something happens but i don't think it
would be that she dies
it would be really tricky to to if they
don't follow her
on her own story and then just to have
her die
abruptly if they brought her back or off
screen even i mean that seems pretty
unsatisfying for that character
rod kiefer thank you thank you for the
199. could saul's i'm not your friend
call be with kim
i don't think so i i mean you know to be
honest i i never liked that in the first
place so there's some bias there but
um
it just yeah i mean she would have to
she'd have to really be turning it on
and just to to keep him away because i
mean she exposed her feelings for what
they were in the last episode i i don't
have any reason to believe that she was
being dishonest there
so um
i don't know what i i feel like saul
could understand that even if he's
acting the way that he's acting so
i don't i don't know why he would he
would be cruel
the bus thumb thank you for the mx20
have you seen the date on the
disabled tag 11 2008 uh that's i'm not
sure i thought that i read that it was
not
an 08 um you're confusing me
uh do you have
any way that i you know i can't really
look at it right at this moment because
i'm in here alone and there's a bunch of
other questions but
my understanding from looking into that
this morning was that there was nothing
to uh contradict the 2005 timeline that
people were
um thinking that this was
i will go and look at it afterwards
though but i mean i i can't do it in the
middle of the stream unfortunately
game like a dylan thank you for the 499
the first scenes of the series showed us
jimmy trying to hold on to the memories
of saul then we thought nostalgia now we
see it as a need to forget yeah we were
just talking about this earlier um
and this you know i get the idea that
this is probably you probably posted
that before or maybe at the same time
and
i absolutely agree i i love that's the
one thing about this episode that that
elevates it even i mean i there's there
was a lot to like about it and there's a
lot that would make it my you know one
of my favorites and
maybe when the recency wears off it'll
it'll slip down from from number one but
uh that was one of the things that that
really contributed to that was just the
amazement that they could uh
they could recontextualize some of these
things in a surprising and satisfying
way this late in the game
pablo osuna thank you for the 4.99 the
cliffhanger will be lyle officially
taking over as the head of new empire
with skinny and badger as the new cooks
maybe
maybe
el juishi thank you for the 199 does
saul still have his uh yeah okay
um thanks for contributing to the uh
to the conversation
asking the important questions
nick lemke thank you for 499 the gap is
bridged between breaking bad and better
call saul so are there any alternate
scenarios you wanted to see
i think lalo running the show in
breaking bad would be great um
you confused me with that last part
there the gap is bridged
so are there any alternate scenarios
that you wanted to see
uh no i i don't know i i never liked the
idea of lalo still being around um just
because i didn't think gus character
made any sense in that i mean i liked
the lalo character i think he was
awesome and uh and of course you know
great to it would be great to have more
time with him but you know story-wise i
didn't think it makes sense i thought
that you know gus had to slay that
dragon before he could become
the character we knew
alternate theories um
i don't know i mean i'm pretty happy
with the way things played out like i
never liked the idea of kim being around
in the background
that seemed a little too cute for for
what it was and the fact that they you
know brought it up from the beginning
that kim is not around and breaking bad
you know like it would have
it would have been
i don't know like just not
not very tasteful to
do that
i can't think of any alternate scenarios
i'm sorry uh nick lick nick lemke um
if something comes to mind in the next
few minutes i'll i'll circle back around
ben landis thank you for the 199. what
are some ways they could screw up the
ending
well they
i mean that's a big question
it all depends on how it hits like i
don't think that
it's hard to imagine um
there's a there was a funny thread
because there was a bunch of those going
around to make up the worst ending
and pretty much all the shows that i
follow on right they that was a trend
this week and there there are some great
ones in there
but um
you know they're they're all funny
they're not supposed to be serious so i
i don't know i mean
if if jimmy
you know if jimmy doesn't redeem himself
that wouldn't that wouldn't necessarily
be
terrible but if they just kind of went
out with like
i don't know if they just went out with
with straight
with nothing
to to get us out of this sad place that
they kind of put us in because like like
i was talking to my guests earlier like
it really the the series re-watching
breaking bad just got a lot sadder you
know i mean like that's a real thing
that happened
with with mike's character gus's
character and definitely saul's
character
so
you know they they could screw up the
ending a little bit if they just
if they didn't do that for a reason
i know it's kind of vague but that
that's just that's the kind of way that
i'm thinking about it
leonardo hernandez thank you for the two
how about the salomon salamancas are not
after papa varga
yeah i think in a in a kind of like a a
sly way they kind you know they kind of
address that and this has always been my
my thought because people
you know that people thought that
you know that the um
that that the nachos ending wasn't good
because they couldn't confirm that that
he would be safe his father would be
safe
and i thought that went against you know
what they were doing
and that you know the thing about that
you have to remember about the cartel is
that
hector is a bad dude but he he can't do
anything if eladio doesn't give him
permission
you know like that's that's really
important that for elaio to hold on to
his power that he has to enforce that
and they you know they showed that
and how lalo was so meticulous this
season
to fake his death and then
you know go after this proof before he
actually moved on on gus even though he
knew his his suspicions about gus were
true
so you know he would they for them to go
after
after his family you know they'd have to
get that
from
elattio and why what does he care about
their personal grudges you know what i
mean like
i think they did a pretty good job of
showing that in this last uh you know
episode that eladio just wants the
business to run
so if they go around killing random
people that aren't in the game then
that's just bad business
jar keras [ __ ] thank you for the 499
walt scene will be him have giving saul
the juice to give to brock since saul
was delivering cash to andrea frequently
it has to be a
crucial scene to breaking bad and i
would disagree with you there
i don't think it has to be a crucial
scene to breaking bad i think it has to
be a crucial scene
to the story of jimmy mcgill saul
goodman
i don't think this show is
at its you know core there to to to
further expand on
the story of breaking bad i think it's
it's it's you know they've tried to make
it a standalone thing
it's great when it does that i'm not
against it when that happens but i just
don't think that's necessary in figuring
out however
i i do agree that that is a possible
place where they could um
bring them back except for i expect them
to be together i expect walt and jesse
to be together when we see them so
that's something to keep in mind too
because obviously you know
they have a a lot of the stuff
a lot of the time in that timeline you
know they're not they're not um
you know they're not
getting along
at times you know
walt is trying to get rid of jesse
david roberts thank you for the two
dollars
what about a
frank abigail ending for jimmy and um
you're gonna make me google aren't you
the name is familiar but i can't
liking it
uh
yeah i don't know i'm not familiar um
it's too difficult for me to look that
up
i'll look into it after the stream's
over i promise
okay
sorry there mr g thank you for the five
again so salt beat d.a erickson's
investigation or maybe she dropped it
kim leaving the profession would have
been suspicious right
gene plus
kim will happen
yeah i i've
you know we talked about i definitely
think that
jim and k
kim and gene have a
they're gonna cross paths um
the erickson thing
yeah i guess
you know i i i don't know if you've
watched the um
the the short the uh
what's the show that uh american greed
that they did
she shows up in that and
and maybe they maybe part of the reason
why they did what that was sort of tie
that together because
um
you know they that
they never really circle back to it but
i mean
she did did she really have an
investigation or did she just have
suspicions and she wanted to pick up an
investigation if she had
someone to work with
it's interesting but i don't have a
great answer for it
darkgate33 thank you for the ten dollars
hello i don't know if this was asked
earlier
but the time skip between the breakup
and jimmy waking up from his bed felt
like a long time what's your opinion i
love the stream
yeah
it seems the consensus is 2005 so maybe
one year
after
when kim left
possibly longer i mean breaking bad the
actual breaking bad timeline is 2008
that's when they first show up but
he shows up in you know season two for
the first time but
based on clues contextual clues it seems
like they're in 2005 so there's still a
gap of time between
what we saw there at the end of this
episode and when breaking bad starts
alrighty
brody thank you for the two dollars any
idea what the next episode title could
mean
nippy uh it's funny because i've been
asking people this in you know behind
the scenes talking and uh
you know i i really like the idea of
them changing now that it's not kim and
jimmy anymore
not having the ans anymore you know that
it's just one words now because
everybody's alone you know and um
the the only thing that i had i think
gil said this organically on his own in
the last stream nippy it you know it
made me think of cold the cold and and
jean is in
you know the snow in the last couple of
gene episodes that we are
installments that we've seen
so that that's what it that's what it
thought about you know i just thought of
loneliness and cold and it's a bit
nipply you know a bit nippy outside
because you know
of where he's at compared to where he
was before
other than that i got nothing i mean
it's a goofy title
kiwi especially he he didn't want to
believe that it existed that it was real
because he just hated the word that that
they were using there
um hassan fayed thank you for the five
would the end of episode nine be the
point when saul meets badger due to the
comment on the
public masturbation
yeah this is uh this we were talking
about this before and i i don't think so
i think it's you know i think jim put it
pretty well when he said you know
this is kind of showing that this is
what he's been doing for you know this
is the kind of stuff he does all the
time he gets these kind of cases all the
time
no no no no
let's see where it's what's next
backs thank you for the five new mexico
handicap tags only have the expiration
date on the tag and are only issued for
a period of one to four years
it's not o eight if the tag says oh
eight okay so maybe that's what this is
talking about what i was saying earlier
i i didn't look into it myself but
i looked into the idea of it over on on
reddit and and um yeah maybe that's
correct if it's
it was the expiration not the year it
was issued
thanks for that
paul
savazlin thank you for the
699 canadian what do you think happened
with gus at the bar just catching
himself from showing his true
orientation
or realizes that papa varga is a loose
end um i would say neither
i think that
my
take on it was that he's consumed by
revenge and that was what what papa was
talking about that it never ends
so i think there's a good a good tie-in
there and i think it's just him saying
like
i think he i think he he he imagined it
you know he had the bottle he had the
the opening to bring this guy into his
world
and i think he allowed himself to have
the fantasy but he won't allow himself
to have that
you know those things that regular
people have i mean there's
there's the obvious thing that he
doesn't you know
he
he he's so focused he's so single-minded
that he has to focus on that his
business his
getting himself to the place where he
can kill everyone in the cartel which is
what what's important to him
but there's also the thing of like maybe
he likes this guy
and he's thinking about it of like the
in the way that kim is thinking about
that she can't be with with jimmy you
know that if he brings this guy into his
life then there's a chance that this guy
might get killed as a result you know
one of his enemies could find out
go after him
he could just be collateral damage you
know what i mean so there's a lot of
things but i think that that's it's
really all about gus and his choice
that
this revenge against the cartel and the
salamancas is all he'll allow
himself and uh not really about the guy
himself
or about you know his orientation or
anything like that
assange
thank you for the 490
449 how does this tie into jessie and
walt can we get some better
understanding of walt's relationship
with gray matter
or jesse and walt in high school i think
that now that we've moved forward in the
timeline that those kinds of things are
less uh
less likely
i think that we're going to see
something that happens during
you know 2008 timeline
and it'll be the way that we saw it
you know the way we saw what saul was
doing
or how it affects soul like we maybe
misinterpreted it originally and that's
what we'll see here is we'll see it from
a different uh we'll see it differently
just sort of like how we see
so many things differently out of this
episode well after we see whatever their
their thing is we'll see some of the
stuff that he does differently going
forward
kevin fentanyl uh thank you for the five
do you think the ending should be happy
or naturalistic
i personally think the latter just like
breaking bad
i don't i don't know i mean you know
it'll depend a little bit on
on what they have to do to get there
the price that they pay for it i guess
there's a way you could say it um
i i don't think that we can expect
something to be purely happy um
for anybody but
i would like to see it
you know
i'd like to see i'd like to know since
we spent so much time getting to know
jimmy mcgill and knowing
the tragedy of that
the good stuff that was in there getting
you know getting removed from his life
but you know by circumstance and by the
choices that he made
i just like to see that you know at the
end of the day he's moving towards he's
moving more towards being that person
again rather than continuing to do what
he's doing
space king thank you for the 2 license
plate says 05 handicap says
08 confirmed and yeah i think
you know what that last
person said was you know
it could be the expiration date so
it's all interesting but
i still think it's 2005.
random youtube comment commentator
commenter
thank you for the r5
i wonder if they'll show one saul
helping emilio
to tuco getting out of prison and taking
hector to his house and three crazy
eight becoming an informant
uh they already showed crazy eight
becoming an informant so i don't think
they need to do that anymore
don't really care about seeing tuko or
hector
i really like the ending they gave us
for hector there and we know tuco comes
back
we can fill in those blanks if we need
to
saul helping emilio um
that feels a little throwaway at this
point
it's a nice little dot that they could
connect if they wanted to but um not
really essential
i mean
like i said that you know breaking bad
is is already good
it doesn't they don't need
they don't really need to like grant
groundwork in for the people that are
transitioning to like it better you know
what i mean um so it should be character
based around the people that we know
from bcs in my opinion
mv thank you for the five do you think
it's possible that there will be a jesse
appearance present day
or do you think they will leave that
story alone love the channel well thanks
for that
yeah i feel like uh
they don't i think
i don't i like thinking of jesse
doing his best up there in alaska trying
to make his way and don't really know
how him coming back in
contact with saul goodman would improve
upon
that um
so yeah i'd like to see him in the
breaking bad timeline instead that'd be
my personal choice but you know this a
lot of times when you think about these
hypotheticals
a lot of stuff that sounds terrible
these are the people that
might be able to pull it off at the same
time so you know what i mean it's not
like when i say i don't prefer something
or don't like something it doesn't mean
that i don't think they can pull it off
if they wanted to
alexander kepchar thank you for the 499.
what did kim mean by mentioning we break
up
in breakup scene as in the only thing
holding them together at that point was
their scam
if not true love
i feel like i wanted to talk about this
with the other guys earlier when they
were here and it never came up
so thank you for the question
i wish i would have seen it a little bit
earlier but um
i don't know that it's a hundred percent
that we're like i don't my take was is
that there's a little bit of ambiguity
there
on the one hand you know
we saw her turn we saw her make that
u-turn
to where you know that that made it i
made it clear that her top priority at
that time was that scam
and so if jimmy
there's an implication that if jimmy
wasn't going to continue on that
then they could actually
they could actually have a breakup
because of that you know i mean because
that's where she was
but there's also other stuff you know i
mean like you know when he said am i bad
for you that's when she went into that's
where she got the idea to
do this to bring him up and then she got
more taken by it than he did you know
and
so yeah i i don't know um that i i it's
something that i'm gonna be looking at i
haven't got a chance to read all the
different
um
reviews and and articles on this yet and
i'll be doing that over the next couple
days and that's one of the things i'm
looking for because i'm sure there'll be
some
some new rey
interviews where maybe she touches on
that a little bit
but um
we'll see
drachara's [ __ ] thank you for the 4.99
jimmy will end up in prison only fitting
ending as he's a criminal lawyer
and he'd be the only character in the
breaking bad universe to end up in jail
i i agree with what you're saying there
that you know it would be a different
ending that we haven't seen yet and
he
you know as far as we know that you know
there's a big bounty for him out there
and
you know it's definitely a possibility i
like if it happens i like it you know
him turning himself in rather than
being caught
but i also would like to watch him do
something crazy that might get him
caught
if that's you know if they if they can
make that work
um i i what i what i mentioned earlier
you know with the other guys is i i
don't what i what i like less is this
idea that we see him in prison or we see
his court
and we see how that plays out and we get
reassured that hey you know what
good old jimmy will be all right in
prison because he's got the right skills
to make friends in there and he can you
know we can be a jail house lawyer i
would like to leave all that up for for
question if if we could
backs thank you for the five again well
walt meet gene
uh no
that that's my that's my take i'll be
i'll be
someone asked earlier what could ruin
the the series and i think like that
could be something that might be able to
ruin the series for me if they if they
brought walt into the gene timeline that
that
this seems like a terrible idea to me
because
for one
the the
you know the
the disappearer isn't what he
what they you know what he advertised
himself to be if if
if walt can find gene you know i mean
like gene should be completely off the
radar you know
gould said that the american greed
segment is concurrent with gene
in the segment walt is still missing not
dead um that's the i didn't know that uh
man i hope not but we'll see um i i i
watched the american greed and i i
thought that was great but i didn't
catch that that um
that it left the door open for those
timelines to overlap
oh i think we got to the end folks
it does appear to be the end and um
i'm definitely i've definitely run out
of steam
uh
if you have a last second question now
would be the time to answer ask it
because i will be
uh
signing off momentarily um so yeah like
i said
saturday we're gonna do one maybe a
little bit earlier but around the same
time saturday night courtney and kiwi
will both be there for sure neither one
of them can make it today uh so
give us a chance to talk about
a little bit of revisiting this stuff
after we had some time to think about it
but more about what comes next and
answer all your questions also
next week we'll be back on tuesday night
we'll see you know uh
how the saturday goes but it might be
two for a while
and um
you know as long as you guys show up
i'll keep doing them and you know i want
to thank you guys for for uh all the
questions and sticking around for three
hours and 10 minutes um
check out my recap if you haven't seen
it yet i've got some more stuff coming
out this week
so keep an eye out
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon